[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
all right so we are live episode number
203 at the new set which by the way if
you can see I don't know if we can show
The Other Side Eric or not we can fit
300 people here and very soon when we
cross 500 000 Subs we'll be doing a live
podcast here drinks maybe cigars maybe
alcohol maybe conversations a lot of
different funny things I will be doing
here so stay tuned for that but with
that being said today's a special
podcast especially after what happened
yesterday with uh the midterms the uh I
don't know if we can call it a red wave
I think it can be called a Sprinkle a
red teardrop we'll talk about that here
in a minute a lot of things happen we
got Adam in the house we got Ricky
Aguilar in the house we got Tom
Ellsworth in the house and we got former
Governor Rod Blagojevich in the house as
well to tell us what really happened
with uh last night oh some stories we
got like some stories for us to know
before we get into it so DeSantis
dominated Rubio dominated Lake uh uh uh
Carey lake with what was going on in
there Arizona apparently it's still
going on right now
everybody from Maricopa to Phoenix
because she said the machines in Phoenix
are working the machines and other
counties weren't working liberal
counting machines are working maybe
we'll talk about that so that's still
taking place musk sold four billion
dollars of stocks uh of Tesla yesterday
uh FTX if you were following the story
just a month ago they were raising a
billion dollars at a valuation of 32
billion dollars just a month ago they
were forced to sell yesterday for one
billion dollars the owner lost 94 of his
net worth in 24 hours okay from 32 and
by the way you know what kind of
investors were involved in FTX we'll
talk about that Tom though some of the
guys one of the guys had seven Super
Bowl champions did you say 94. 94 Equity
lost in one day in FTX it's weird that
also the nft marketplace has it's been
quiet 94 as well
ethereum's right now 1200 anyway some
investors this is a Wall Street Journal
article talking about that fed rates
could hit two decade High six percent
Facebook laying off 11 000 homeowners
lost one and a half trillion dollars in
equity just in the last five uh five uh
months and then we'll talk politics
we'll talk some polls and we'll talk
some issues but with that being said how
do you feel about last night uh Tom why
don't we go to you first what happened
last night you were up till three
o'clock in the morning well you were
looking for a wet Red Wave and then
you're looking for maybe a little bit of
a red high tide and what you ended up
with is sort of a a midterm shift but of
the more neutral sedate type and we
still have some things we're out looking
it's 48 48 in the Senate we still got
four races that are really close a
runoff gonna happen in Georgia I think
that's pretty much determined now and
then three races that are pretty close
although laxalt looks good in Nevada but
I really saw sort of
you you thought that the voter was going
to be more Angry in the voting booth you
saw exit polls from all the different
channels talking about how upset the
voters were but inside the voting booth
there wasn't as much shift as we
anticipated which one rod surprised you
the most which one was yeah I kind of
saw that one come in I did not see XYZ
coming which one was it I mean which
race which race which particular race
well a Kerry Lake doesn't win that'll be
a shock to me if she doesn't yeah I
think she's going to win I don't know a
lot about what's going on in Arizona but
I just feel like the campaign she was
running she's a very attractive
candidate forceful
um if she doesn't win that'll be the
biggest surprise am I surprised about
the result in other words what Tom said
wasn't a red wave it was probably a dark
pink wave
um yes a little bit surprised but here
again if you're asking me who the
biggest losers are I would say it's the
pollsters and the pundits I would say
that it's a republican expectations I
would say it's the Democrats still
because they in all likelihood will not
have total control of the government
um and if you're asking about who the
winners are clearly Ron DeSantis had a
big big night big winner the Republican
party in Florida big winner and hoodies
are big Winners and the next time I run
for public office I'm gonna get a hoodie
and I'm going to run this no suit and
time I'm going to order a hoodie and
it's going to say across my chest I
didn't do it like fetterman like
fetterman yeah I mean who else would you
say biggest biggest winners are losers
go ahead
well I it's um
I think everything comes down to D now
let me explain so who are the biggest
losers it's not even close Donald Trump
was the biggest loser of the night okay
in addition to that election denialism D
massive loser we can go down the ticket
here every single governor
in in in swing states that was running
on the election denial ticket okay
whether it's Tom Michaels Wisconsin
tutor Nixon Michigan Doug mastriano
Pennsylvania got wiped out okay Darren
Bailey dancogs Illinois Maryland Lee
Zelda in New York I know they said they
thought they'd be close wasn't and then
Kerry Lake
um and then last but not least Lee
Shelton was closed for for the state of
New York for New York but it was New
York that's right for 4.7 percent I
think 47 to 52.4 not not close enough
but it was going to change anything yeah
you just went close and then last but
not least and this is where I think
Republicans shot themselves in the foot
in addition to just you know
following everything that Trump says and
denialism was the Dobbs decision the
last D which was the abortion issue this
should have been a freaking layup for
Republicans we've been talking about a
red wave for six months and this isn't
barely a red teardrop with everything
that's going on in the country dude I
voted for Ron DeSantis okay we'll talk
about what the winners are with
everything that's going on in the
country right now whether whether it's
inflation the cost of living gas prices
crime immigration this should have been
a Wipeout and it wasn't even close so I
agree with Governor Robert Blagojevich
that
um
the you said the uh what was your point
of who who was the uh the big winner
uh well the scientists the Florida
Republican party okay hoodies and the
but the on the flip side who the big
winners were were DeSantis not even
close Okay Democrats because there was
no red wave of it but the the Big D is
democracy so
the Democrats had no platform
their entire platform was just let women
choose and protect democracy who cares
what's going on in the economy who cares
how shitty inflation is who cares let's
protect democracy bottom line is it
turns out election denialism is not a
winning message so if you're a
Republican and you're thinking huh 2024
is around the corner who should I get
behind it's obvious don't let emotions
in the in the window here it's obvious
the electorate is saying go with
DeSantis he just destroyed Florida
Miami-Dade which never votes red
meanwhile everyone that basically was on
the Trump train and the denialist ticket
lost it's clear Trump is a toxic
candidate
40 percent of America loves this guy 60
wants nothing to do with them so you
know this there's something called Big
Tent politics you have to have a big
tent it's a it's a numbers game if you
don't get to 50 you're not going to win
we had uh Dinesh D'Souza another D I
asked him the other what was the thing
he did 2 000 mules I said I said why are
you shocked that
Trump lost he wasn't the favorite he
goes what are you talking about and I
brought up the Vegas odds I go
yeah he wasn't the favorite how did you
not know that he's like Oh I thought
Trump was the favorite brother you just
made an entire documentary you made a
hundred million dollars and you didn't
know that Trump wasn't the favorite
denialism is not the way forward okay
sore loser victim mentality is not the
way forward
DeSantis Freedom that's the way forward
but if you nominate Trump in 2024 you
got another thing coming Republicans
that's it's actually a very good
conversation do you what do you think
about what Adam just said well I agree
with a lot of what he's saying I would
say this if it wasn't for the Dobb's
decision and reversing Roe v Wade that
would have been a republican Red Wave I
do believe that I think women all over
the country in every part of the country
saw that as an affront of their freedoms
their rights it's a moral issue and I
certainly understand the people who
believe life begins at conception I
understand if you believe that they have
to take the position that they take but
most Americans don't think that and I
think that notwithstanding the fact that
the polls before the election was
indicating that that was an issue that
was further down the concerns of the
voter that was the economy and crime and
in the open borders and and the abortion
issue wasn't that high I think women got
into the voting booth and they first of
all they came out in larger numbers I'm
sure and they were driven by the the
fact that the idea of politicians and
men in particular can restrict their
reproductive freedoms and we tell them
about their bodies I think that had a
big impact in this race let me add to
that timing is very important you know
timing is of the essence if I'm the
Republicans
and if you really really wanted to do
the you know repeal Rover suede I would
have done it right after you won the Red
Wave midterms let's be clear the reason
you lost the midterms was because
election denialism is not a winning
message sorry Donald Trump and number
two women got pissed off they're like
hold on Republicans are in charge now
and now I'm losing my reproductive
choice I ain't down for this so if they
would have done it as far as timing goes
right after they had a mandate in 2022
which they would have if they didn't
shoot themselves in the foot over this
abortion issue then they would have had
a mandate that said we're in charge now
we hold Congress because they would have
and then that would have been an
opportune moment to do that instead they
jumped the gun and now they're paying
the price in basically maybe not even
holding Congress I think they're going
to win the house but they're not going
to win the Senate that's pretty clear
then it's 48 48 right now and one of
them uh Georgia is going to be what a
runoff which we're not going to know
anything for 30 days and then uh uh but
there's the the Senate the the Arizona
seat could it's still going on no uh LAX
Hall overnight uh things have tightened
up in Nevada and he actually has a 22
000 vote lead right now
um yes don't know if all the rural
Arizona is going to come in is going to
bring Masters up it seems like he's got
a long way to go right there and Mark's
got that one in hand so I I think the
best case is probably 50 50. I think
it's probably Georgia Nevada if Herschel
Walker wins the runoff is probably the
best case on the Republican side and
it's 50 50. something you said that I
was looking at last night is the
pollsters and political Consultants are
big losers they are charging exorbitant
fees to candidates and I see you nodding
you were a candidate you went through
that you had to determine who are the
right ones to hire for your campaign
today in an economic malaise or today
when it's up and you had all the things
that you had to do I took a look just at
Florida last night I went to Real Clear
Politics I went to 538 because they
assimilate all these different polls and
you can see them and there is a worst
case scenario I saw a couple of them
that were nine point polls for DeSantis
most everything I found was seven seven
and a half eight it was a 20 Point
Victory so somewhere over at Charlie
Chris camp they're looking at some
checks they wrote to these consultants
and pollsters and saying what the hell
why didn't we know the hole was this
deep they would have spent their money
differently similarly I looked at
Whitmer it was off by like like half her
her victory was double the spread they
thought it was going to be and the
reason I looked at those races in
neither race was there like a last
minute surprise or a booby trap or
something right you you look you looked
at DeSantis in Florida Xanax didn't cure
cancer Charlie Chris didn't have some
horrible thing pop up of a fraternity
picture or something it did you know
what I'm saying the election just rolled
right in no surprises
and I think the pollsters those were
just two I looked at but the polls were
so wrong of not really understanding
this and I'm wondering is if polling
America is on something that's so deeply
lightning rod as Choice abortion and
with women do we just not want to be
pulled and just they're they're not
finding ways to get the right answers
because the pollsters were massive
losers I agree with you on that point I
mean this is the
umpteenth time we've been like well the
pollsters were wrong again what's the
definition of crazy doing the same thing
over and over again and expecting
different results we know this of course
Ricky knows the crazy definition
um but in 2016 the pollsters were
absurdly wrong right 2018 2020 again
Biden was the favorite now 2022. I told
you the one poll that I look at it's not
Pew it's not Rasmussen it's not ABC it's
not Fox all that I just look at Vegas
bro what's Vegas doing because there's
accountability there they you know
follow the money if they lose they
really lose exactly if they lose they
lose like we just saw this guy Mattress
Mack ones 75 million dollars because he
put it on the Astros there's
accountability there oh [ __ ] we just
lost our line was way off okay versus
what's the accountability with these
pollsters
there's no accountability Well turns out
we were way wrong well all right can you
write me another check for the next you
know elections around it's there's no
accountability there in Vegas at least
there's accountability if they screw up
somebody's getting fired and they're
going to pay out 75 million bucks these
polls are absurd Ricky what are you
thinking
um you know I'm listening I was kind of
listening to the guys at first and I was
thinking about like I was listening to
to Adam right now about
um
you know when I'm I talk to a lot of
people when it comes out to this with
with the whole thing with Trump and
why not
um I think that
I think that what really affected the
Republican party was a hundred percent
even because I know even conservative
women that are not happy with the fact
that they don't get to choose or they
can't choose uh how they're going to be
able to deal with their bodies as far as
um being able to uh uh have the choice
to either keep a baby or not so more
than just
the fact that
people did not
the people were concerned about gas and
they're concerned about mortgage ration
they're concerned about taxes it's more
than obvious they're more concerned
about things that are personal to them
what then it comes out to their body I
think that that's that's kind of what we
saw I'm like I said I'm extremely
surprised with a lot of things that were
happening but then again
when you start talking to Everyday
Americans and you start to spin the
stories like they have with Democrat
Party about like oh everything's fine
everything's fine so many people are so
emotionally attached to their political
parties that they're going to believe
they're politicians like look what
happened in California knew someone
again
he
sent his kids to school we couldn't send
our kids to school he was partying at a
birthday party in the middle of a
pandemic we couldn't do that he did he
did everything that was recorded doing
everything that we couldn't do and they
voted him again
I just really hey by the way in
California if you were in California he
was hitting the abortion thing really
hard
and like I said even conservative women
even Republican women that I know that
we're not down with that you know I'm
pro-life I I believe the life you know
you know you don't I don't people don't
have to agree with it but the Bible says
you know hey I knew you before you were
in the womb that means something to me
but most of the people are not picking
up a Bible so therefore they're not
strongly attached to that ideology and I
think that in this more than the fact
that Trump was saying oh everybody
cheated in 2020 I think they're more
they were more concerned about the
reproductive organs issue that they were
about him denying the fact that you know
it was a bad election Scott Rodriguez
just asked you a question uh he said
what's up with Latinos Ricky when will
they wake up here in California no the
thing is that I don't I don't think that
I don't it's not that they're not waking
up there's not enough of them right
there's not enough for them and on top
of that you can't go like for example no
matter how much people know in
California I
and it's funny because some of my
cousins are going to be watching this
I'm a republican I'm a Conservative
Republican but what happens is that they
can't fathom the idea of voting the
opposite of what they've been told or
what they've been taught every time I go
to my in-laws house or I go to my
grandmother's house
Telemundo all these companies all these
all these uh uh Mexican cnns are talking
about how the Democrat Party is a savior
of everybody
so no matter how much Logic the the
reason the reason that in Mexico a lot
of people around won't take long on the
subject but a lot of people forget that
Mexicans originally we were not Chris we
were not Catholic we worshiped the son
of the Moon they came and changed our
religion because we believe the the
problem with Hispanic Community is that
we believe people just because they're
on the TV
and we think they're right we're we're
not want to do our homework sounds like
we're here to get on TV very gullible
people so I know so no matter what
happens no matter what conversation I
have with my grandparents or uncles I
have an aunt in particular I'm not going
to say her name I have it on in
particular that I can show her all the
facts as she still will refuse to vote
the other way because she can't fathom
the idea of voting Republican even
though that's what benefits her the most
you have a brother that works both sides
of the aisle I don't know if you ever
watched Jordan klepper fingers the pulse
The Daily Show by the way just as far as
The Daily Show Goes anyone watch The
Daily Show I haven't really watched it
since Jon Stewart left I'm not a fan of
the uh
I can't even forget I can't remember his
name who's the hosted what's his name
Trevor Noah Trevor Noah not a fan cool
all good but Jordan Clepper is a
freaking star and he goes out so we can
talk all day how Wild and wacky the woke
left is but this guy who's clearly a
liberal talented guy comedian goes into
the heart of trump country red America
rule America and asks Everyday People
doesn't doesn't assume ask questions and
the answers are wildly insane
they're like January 6 was just a
peaceful March it was there was no there
was no any nothing happened what
yeah one lady was like oh yeah I don't
believe any of that none of that was all
fake no there was no issues there was no
violence it's like well what's this he
shows it to her she's like I don't
believe it so like denialism is real
most people
are most people most people no I don't
know I must say the nihilism is real I
don't think it's the biggest subject as
we think it is more than the
reproductive organ part well all right
so if we're gonna go there
I've been pretty clear Republicans
should have run away with this this is
an ABC of old people exit polls most
important issues number one by far was
inflation 32 percent number two was an
abort was abortion 27 percent shouldn't
even been on the ballot I'll be clear
about that shouldn't have been on the
ballot and then the next three major
issues were crime 11 gun policy 11
immigration 10 those are all winning
issues for Republicans those are
inflation crime gun policy immigration
those are layup W's for Republicans but
they threw in this abortion thing
overreached and said we got this thing
guys no you don't know we're showing you
right now it was a reproductive organ
thing exactly I don't know if I'm going
to put that guy he's like oh that's it
and that's the no but let me let me say
what you just said right now with
January 6th I think the biggest
challenge I think for myself wasn't
January 6th whether that was just a
peaceful protest it was the fact the
opposing side I called what happened
with the riots a peaceful protest so you
lose credibility so one goes to court
and you want to put people in jail but
the other one they're just peaceful
protesters and they're ruining their own
communities so so to me the
contradiction there is on both sides
fully on your side two wrongs don't make
sure floors yesterday Milo floors lost
last time she lost last time which is
pretty uh but this is a tweet that she
put yesterday I want to get your
thoughts on this if you can pull it up
she said the Red Wave did not happen
Republicans and independents stayed home
do not complain about the results if you
did not do your part so what do you
think about this tweet from Myra Flores
and Ricky I'll quote you first she's
right she's 100 right she should have
won
she should have won she was she's
popular she's popular I mean she should
have won she's not she's not wrong when
again when we go back and we're watching
all the when we're watching all the the
the the the the polls and we're watching
how close a lot of these races are it's
it that's not that's not that's not how
this thing was supposed to be nobody
projected it to be this way and she's
right I think a lot of people simply
either either they were big on the
abortion thing or they just did not show
up and but by the way just so you know
just going back I don't want to go back
backtrack Pat but you see a lot of
Hispanics really do believe that your
vote doesn't count just so you know that
like a lot of my boys are like bro I'm
not going to go vote for California it
doesn't well I know but I'm saying they
believe that in general it's a general
belief but in this case she was ready
for house Kennedy right that's a little
bit different than running for governor
because you're talking about in the
house you're talking about a district
we're not talking about the whole state
correct so she lost her District but a
lot of people don't think that they're
vocals that's very popular amongst the
Hispanic community that your vote
doesn't count
who did she lose to uh what was the um
Tyler
I can't remember who uh Myra Flores yeah
who did she lose
I
was following so many of these
if you can pull up who she lost to
because and while we're looking at that
there's a whole issue in in Texas and if
you were to take a look at the the
governor county map and you see that
there were really there are three
Texas's now there is all of the
communities that go on the border
um the Rio Grande RGV you know Corpus
you know everything all the way down
there on the border then you've got
rural Texas and then you've got core
Houston core Austin and core Dallas and
they're like blue dots and you look at
what happened in what avabido O'Rourke
and so Beto O'Rourke lost again
um and what was interesting about that
is you look how we lost he didn't lose
his bad on the border communities which
stayed blue for him because of turnout
so she's right there was a the the
turnout was not down there and I think
they thought they had this thing covered
and even the poll the polls were wrong
on you know so Beto lost by more and the
polls were off but you have to look at
where everything was and it was really
eye-opening if you've got that map at
some point to take a look at what the
Border communities were for Beto
O'Rourke versus the rest of the state
beta was running for governor he was
running against Abbott yeah good
question about Beto you lived in Texas
for a decade and the same way has that
guy won anything when's the last time he
won anything no I mean listen not
Statewide no you have to you have to so
so this is this is the part like all I'm
thinking about is as a strategist a few
things you got to be thinking about so
by the way this school the reason why I
asked who she lost so she lost a guy
named Vicente Gonzalez if you read the
comments go back to the Myra tweet that
I just gave you can you pull that up and
just go to the comment section below
just zoom in a little bit so we can read
what people are saying what people are
saying zoom in zoom in a little bit it's
not allowing okay there you go look at
the first comment a Democratic candidate
with 2 000 Twitter followers beats you
let that sink in you have 371 000
followers
do no Democratic Congressman Vince
Vincente Gonzalez just passed just won
over 2 000 followers you got rejected
right go a little lower then he said
unto Felicia keep going Lord keep going
Lord keep going Lord keep going lower
wrong we did our part we showed up in
record numbers and voted you out bye-bye
massive L all this stuff that they say
here's the part I also don't know if I'm
if I if I uh if I run a sales
organization and one of my sales guys
goes out there and says well listen guys
you guys didn't show up and you didn't
do your part that's why we lost you guys
didn't sell no no the leader gets the
responsibility I I don't think this
concept about you didn't go shaking off
hands I'd much rather put the onus on
myself if you look at Charlie Christie's
first candidate ever to lose a Statewide
okay election as an independent as a
Republican and as a Democrat no one
likes a flip-flopper it's the reason why
a John Kerry is not a president and his
entire trajectory since he was in high
school was this guy's one they're gonna
end up being a what he he looks like a
president he looks like Lincoln if you
put him side by side they have a similar
kind of a look similar height he's a
flip-flop American people don't like
that Beto O'Rourke is just not a good
leader he's not a candidate that's it's
formidable so both the left and the
right and certain areas chose somebody
that was not good for that market so a
Dr Oz may have done better in a
different Market you don't relate to
Pennsylvania so so the candidate you
chose for that market a person that's
worth 75 million dollars you want me to
go in Pennsylvania get the votes of
people that are like dude I don't relate
to you you know I don't I don't live
your life I don't have that so there's
some of these things now Trump worked in
the National
you know uh uh election as when he ran
for office president but he had a
Swagger he pushed Trump that OS was
maybe like him so both sides get a bit
of a blame on NBA draft something went
out there this morning Barstool Sports
tweeted something which was so funny
they showed a clip where the the uh
attorneys asking Michael Cohen in court
how many times more than a hundred times
more more than 200 times more more than
500 times about 500 times and in
Barstool Sports puts the amount of times
the Oakland Raiders screwed up on a
draft pick right first rapping the point
is both sides picked the wrong candidate
they got behind and you screwed up so if
you won in an area great if you're lost
in an area great the one area you're
saying issue I agree with you on the
fact that Roe v Wade timing but when
they did it I think Supreme Court was
6-3 then it one two five four so you
didn't really want to take the risk of
waiting this long because it could have
gone the other way anyway so they kind
of had to do it at the time so this
just so you know it didn't go six three
so if we would have been five four and
they would have done that maybe would
have gone four or five so that's the
risk that Republicans did take but if
you're talking about winners and losers
I'll give you my thoughts on winners and
losers okay
hardcore winner at the top above
everything is copy whatever policies the
scientists did in the State of Florida
period that's number one I think you're
right number one biggest winner is him
Rubio won it wasn't even close uh
DeSantis one and I like his message I
don't know if you heard the speech when
he gave his speech by the way they
announced him at like seven o'clock yeah
four o'clock it was like the first time
first thing oh this one forget about it
at 37 60 they're like yeah it's over
with it's done with and then he got up
and he says a lot of you I because he
didn't win uh the first time uh uh by
widespread it was a very narrow margins
or something yeah I don't know what the
number was maybe wrong with 35 000.
put them over because it was such a
close race it was such a close race you
came in there and people charged for
this answers but this time he won by
like 1.4 1.5 million so he said
something he says I also want to thank
many of you who didn't vote for me the
first time correct but you're voting for
me now I want to thank you for earning
your vote yes it's a very interesting
messaging right on what he's saying so
Florida one it's definitely not a win
for Maga Community there's no question
about it that's not a a win I think to
be honest with you I think the American
voter won I think small business kind of
won here's why there's going to be a
gridlock nothing's going to get done the
next two years if you don't like Biden
you're okay if you don't like
Republicans you're okay yeah no one's
going to be able to push anything
through it's kind of going to be like
next two years you don't even need to
watch CNN on Fox right now for the next
two years maybe next six months 12
months next year 2020 focus on yourself
not politics but but the point being
there isn't anybody that's going to sit
there worried about anything's going to
be
push through so on that part I think the
winners also the small business owner
the American voter uh I think those who
don't like Nancy Pelosi are definitely
very excited okay the fact that you
don't have to hear from her anymore okay
maybe even her husband is happy because
she can spend more time with them at the
hospital I don't know maybe he's going
to be a hospital you know so who knows
about what's going to happen
McCarthy's from Bakersfield
yeah it's a HomeTown guy you talk about
leadership and I think there's really
something there and I I I'd like to ask
you this question it appears to me when
you look at DeSantis he had two crisises
I remember the governors we talked about
this the first time you're on the
podcast about how the governors are
really there's really only 51 CEOs in
America the president and 50 Governors
everybody else is a legislator if you
think of it right um The Government Can
the governor can call the National Guard
he can do a lot of things he's got
executive orders president cut executive
orders you can do things like a CEO
DeSantis had two major crises covid and
hurricane Ian and in both cases he made
choices that benefited his state three
days you rebuild a bridge exactly what
are you talking about we got the bridge
built and back in there to get Emergency
Equipment and fresh water and things in
there and he's walking around and people
are making fun of him walking around on
his white rubber boots but the point is
wait a minute he's been down I was
looking at this I said the guy's been
down there for a week he had a command
center he's making decisions I think you
got to give credit to the Florida voter
that said this guy's doing a good job
and he's doing things and I'm voting for
him and so the surprise that well
Miami-Dade should be automatic blue
what's going on here I think people
looked at that when you were Governor
did you feel there's my question did you
feel that when you did things and
Leadership was on display that it would
Trump the standard not mean Trump but it
would overpower just walking in the
voting booth and pulling the the
one-party lever oh absolutely I had the
misfortunately getting reelected because
I think I did a good job as governor and
then of course Calamity came and had to
go away for eight years but uh no of
course you run as the incumbent on your
record if you have one and uh if you've
done a good job most of the time if not
all the time the people as Bill Clinton
used to say almost always get it right
and they and they reward you for that
and I think your analysis of Governor
desantis's performance is the governor
taking strong positions sticking to him
um handling the emergency that happened
which was frankly a political benefit to
him because they pay the ability to be
able to handle a crisis and do it in the
middle of a campaign where the other
guys campaigning and you look like you
are being a leader and you're doing
things for the people it's a tremendous
political advantage that he had I want
to point out it was a big win for him I
don't know that Charlie Chris was such a
good candidate Rubio did almost as good
as DeSantis so it's a bigger Trend than
just to santis it's a republican Trend
in Florida and I think it would have
happened in other places had there been
what the decision from the Supreme Court
didn't happen and had there been better
candidates running candidate quality
makes a big difference and if you're
disappointed because it didn't go
completely your way there's a lot of
Hope for the Republican party because
what's happening down in America
gradually it's a gentle political
realignment Latinos increasingly our
voting Republican leaving the Democratic
party black men are little by little
leaving the Democratic party leaving
what Harold Washington the first
African-American mayor of Chicago called
Plantation politics leaving that
politics of dependency government
Democrats just giving you crumbs but not
really investing in the community and
giving people a chance to have
opportunities they are moving slowly to
the Republican party where the
Republican party is losing are those
Suburban women white Suburban women and
notwithstanding that poll by The Wall
Street Journal that said there was a 27
point shift of right of Republican
Suburban white women I still think when
they made the decision to go vote I
think a lot of them just said I don't
want government or men telling me what I
can do about my body I agree with you I
think that that was a big I think to
like going back to that I think it was
the biggest issue I think it was a much
bigger issue than than a lot than a lot
of people predicted it would be I think
that I think that the Republican party
when it came down to that message
thought that all the Republicans and
conservatives were going to back up that
message and they didn't because even
though like I'm pro-life and I still
don't think the government should tell
people what to do with their body I just
I just don't I just I mean I just don't
and so and I'm like and I'm very deep
rooted in my in my beliefs and I still
don't think the government has any any
business telling people what to do
because it's it's here when it comes
down to it's it goes back to um
hypocrisy right like if you wanted the
vaccine or didn't want the vaccine you
know like you were you wanted to have a
choice with that but you don't want to
give women the choice even if you don't
agree with it I I think it was a bad bad
messaging for the Republican party it
ended up being the covet of this
election
yeah good point whoa technology the
abortion yeah no one realized it but the
abortion decision ended up being the
covid issue of this election yeah we
keep going back back to the premise of
candidates right uh I think Chris
Christie who's becoming more of like a
just a normal moderate voice that's
needed in America uh he said something
very profound yesterday speaking of you
know you being a candidate and being an
incumbent he said being an incumbent and
being competent is a lethal mix so look
at uh lethal in a good way you look at
Iran DeSantis he was at the incumbent
and he was very competent blowout so you
even look in Georgia Brian Kemp yeah he
blew out Stacey Abrams out of the water
he was the incumbent and now he was real
close four years ago very close four
years four years ago against um Stacey
Abrams now it wasn't even close right
and he you know he earned speaking of
suburban women he curryed a lot of favor
in Georgia
for standing up to Trump okay so Trump
is like
he's he's rooting against certain
Republicans he's kind of if you're on
team Maga he's rooting for you but if
Brian Camp who just won he's rooting
against wildly
um but back to candidates so like you
brought up
um fetterman
so Mehmet Oz oh my God here's a guy that
talk about National presence everyone's
seen him on TV for a decade and a half
okay he's not even from Pennsylvania he
loses to like the Modern Day Weekend at
Bernie's this guy just had a stroke six
months ago they're propping him up there
on strings like Pinocchio and you can't
beat that guy I mean what is going on
here like the candidacy and he was hand
picked by Donald Trump well that's
another issue about figuring out a way
where these different states have
different ways of voting in Pennsylvania
over a million people voted before that
debate where Federal Manhattan early
difficulties and they were
overwhelmingly probably fetterman votes
and I I wonder if there hadn't been that
early of an early votes good point had
there been a debate before the Iran
voting but there's also like even
different you know there's also sound
bites that resonate so for instance what
was like Ronald Reagan's famous sound
buddies there you go again was that
there you go exactly and it's like I'm
not gonna let uh my age or what was that
whole age and experience like sound
bites but the sound bite in that
Pennsylvania election is like how you
gonna vote for us he's a Cowboys fan now
if you if you live in Pennsylvania and
you're a Steelers fan Steelers country
Eagles and that guy or an Eagles or same
division who are a good friend of mine
Dylan bed David thinks is going to win
the Super Bowl this year because he's
got you know those skills like that but
if you're identified as a Cowboys fan in
PA you're not winning homie like that's
it let me read this those things matter
let me read this you know as a bulls fan
as a bear's fan from from yesterday CNN
fetterman sues to have mail-in ballots
counted even if not signed with validate
this is a CNN story okay about fetterman
about fetterman the question of whether
mailed ballots would incorrect or
missing dates can be counted in one of
the hottest voting disputes in the
pivotal State leading up to election day
and a divided Pennsylvania Supreme Court
recently ordered counties to refrain
from Counting mail ballots with missing
or invalid dates on their outer
envelopes so Pennsylvania Democratic
Senate nominee John Federman and voters
campaign has aligned with hoping the
federal court will supersede the state's
Court decision the date in instruction
imposes unnecessary hurdles that
eligible pennsylvanians must clear to
exercise their more their most
fundamental right resulting in our
otherwise valid votes being arbitrarily
rejected without any reciprocal benefit
of the Commonwealth the date on a male
ballot envelope thus has no bearing on a
voter's qualification and serves no
purpose other than to erect barriers to
qualified voters exercising their
fundamental constitutional right to vote
this unnecessary impediment violates the
Civil Rights Act in the first and 14th
Amendment to the U.S Constitution what
do you think about what fetterman says
here when he's saying he's going to sue
he probably won't Sue now that he's been
projected do you agree with him on what
he's like is that no I think I think we
have to tighten up these laws that's
what I'm saying like when you hear
stories like this yes of course what do
you mean if signatures are missing
school to count if dates are missing
still to count these are the types of
things when you say and Adam you talk
about the the election denier well I
think what that does when people because
here's what's going to happen now you
know how you categorize somebody as a uh
Trump person that person's automatically
going to be judged because they're a
trump person right right
here's what I'm for I'm for if like in
Florida they were trying to do something
around the sentence he says uh we're not
pulling this off here uh story came out
about what the Santa said two days ago I
think even yesterday Florida rejects
Federal monitors inside polling places
not permitted the DeSantis
Administration warned Biden's Department
of Justice late Monday that federal
election date poll monitors are not
permitted inside polling places under
Florida law and said on Friday will send
its own monitors to ensure there is no
interference to the voting process on
Monday the doj released a list of 64
jurisdictions with 24 States in which
the department plans to send attorneys
to monitor for compliance with Federal
voting right laws on Election Day
included on that list was Broward
Miami-Dade and Palm Beach County in
Florida Brad McVeigh general counsel to
Florida's Department of State said the
Section 102 point he's got all these
things here of the Florida State
statutes statutes list of people who may
enter any polling room or polling place
Department of Justice Personnel are not
included on this list so
you know DeSantis is saying you know get
out of this place fetterman is saying we
should count these guys that signature
is not being counted uh uh Carey lake is
telling voters go for Maricopa County to
Phoenix because Phoenix is more liberal
none of the machines were having issues
the other ones were having issues some
people are waiting in line three four
five hours these are the types of things
that get people to say if we have
technology the way that we do today why
can't we make this more compliant clear
easy that we can trust you know in
Florida whatever you vote you can go on
a website look at your vote track the
two see if it was counted or not State
of Florida does that wow you know how
many states you can do that in not many
in many states you can't even figure out
if your vote counted or not you don't
know it's just kind of like did they
count it or not ah just trust us we got
it so I think I I do think whoever like
uh uh uh I think was Ron Rand Paul says
you know I'm gonna make it my mission to
go after fauci on every single thing
moving forward the next two years and
you know he's going to be doing it which
he did you know he's going to be doing
it right but I also think there's got to
be a more because a part of when people
say things like Ricky is saying they
don't think their vote's going to count
there's a lot of people also feel that
way I don't think it's just Hispanics
there's a lot of people that say I don't
know if my voice going to count or not I
think we got to get people to trust that
a little bit more than they do today the
last six years trust has gone a little
bit lower in these voting methods that
we have we can streamline that to
increase trust in the voting message
that we have can I get in here real
quick and I just want to it's a
wholeheartedly agree with what you're
saying if you're asking me what is
probably the biggest short-term
challenge in America is isn't the issue
of saving the Democracy that was a bunch
of Hyperbole and baloney you can swear
here right a lot of [ __ ] because if
the Republicans had a wave these are
talking points yeah but it did speak to
a whole group of Democrats because they
have such distrust for Republicans on
the other hand when you talk about
election denial There's real reasons
that people don't trust the electoral
system there is real fraud I come from
Chicago Obama and I both know how that
happens and how it's done in big cities
now did that change the outcome of the
last presidential election it doesn't
make any sense to dig that up and keep
talking about it you should move forward
but to get Trust of the American people
to believe in the Integrity of these
elections is critical and a debt
Republican house can do this a great
service to the American people if they
push something that streamlines the
process Nationwide and doing it in a way
where there's certain guidelines that
every state has to follow so that the
people can trust the outcome they'll be
more apt to vote and they'll be more
willing to accept the other side winning
if they honestly think it was a fair
game but right but if the people don't
think so but Maricopa this is the second
time they have issues they did it during
the 2020 election right or they're well
they were saying their machines were
counting if you're ordering Republicans
going Democrat it was an accident
maricopa's already lost their their
credibility when it comes on to that
yeah like when they were bringing up
Maricopa I was like oh here we go again
that's what went through my mind it
wasn't like Oh Oh that's oh wow no it's
like no so I at the same point it gets
to a point where people are just tired
of the [ __ ] and and I don't you know
you you come from that so you're gonna
know but I think that power corrupts and
I believe that you know and we learned
that in the Bible Bible teaches that and
and I'm going to tell you that I think
that once you find a way to win and you
can get away with it once on such a big
skill I am 100 I will say publicly I do
not care whatever it is what it is we
all have our opinions and I I 100 do not
believe the 2020 election was fair
election I do believe it was rigged
um that's all there is to it there's
nobody nobody's going to convince me
otherwise but the point is this that
um I I believe that once you get away
with something that's such a big scale
the way they in my head again this is
100 my opinion this is not something I'm
trying to shove other than other people
so I don't even talk about this subject
but once you figure out like dude if we
can put the president in office then we
can pick our Senators too we can pick
our Governors too I think once you
figure out a way to cheat once you're
gonna do it multiple times in certain
States in certain states of course of
course in certain states which which by
the way it's one of the reasons why but
that's all you need to flip a house no
you're right I don't disagree with you
you're right but all I'm saying to you
is it's also the reason why we moved our
media company to Florida yeah it's also
why Texas is still winning it's also why
a a must in a Rogan and others moved to
Austin and they're moving to Texas
because that model worked under covid
it's it's also why a purple State like
Florida is turning red because people
are sitting there saying listen man I
feel a little bit more comfortable
living in a place like this but you're
absolutely right again
when when when dams put the blanket
statement on you to say he's an election
denier listen these are very very
effective methods let me give you some
words okay some words that you put
somebody in how differently people look
at that person okay uh if somebody calls
somebody cue that person's career may be
over okay if somebody calls somebody q
that person's query could be over if
somebody calls somebody a racist that
person's career may be over if somebody
calls somebody an anti-semite right that
person's career may be over election
denier anti-vaxx how many of these do we
have we have so many of these that we
can put there right and what that does
is unfortunately get some people to be
quiet and say well I'm definitely not
going to touch up on that topic no I
still think the average person doesn't
fully trust
the the voting process and by the way I
think that's on the left and right I
think the average person doesn't trust
whether their vote really matters as
well as whether the system they really
trust or not I think till today people
on both sides still feel that way I
could tell you right now there are
certain people on the left that are
sitting there saying how is it even
possible for Kerry Lake to be so close
she just is she who is she she was a fox
a local TV and she's now who is she to
have that kind of I guarantee you
there's people on the left that are
saying how can that person want that
County how is it even possible that this
can be happening so if both sides have a
little bit uncomfortable think about
this let's just make some progress on
this part here and and some people this
is the part if you want to find out uh
for example if you want to find out
somebody that is not happy with their
body fat percentage how do you find out
you know like look for example you you
fastest way hey guys you know what we
want to do what's that let's all get on
the scale and see how much we weigh if a
person says what no yeah I'm a good bad
but if something if a person says that
what are they saying to you they're
they're not happy they're embarrassed
with what their weight is at right if we
say hey let's throw everybody's body fat
percentage nah man I'll skip this I
gotta go to the bathroom my stomach
hurts right if if everybody in the room
says guys why don't we use technology to
make our election process smoother more
accurate if the people in the room say
no guess what you're worried about your
weight that's my concern if you are
about progress let's make progress with
technology as well because we got plenty
of bright people
that can do it by the way you know what
I do like here's what I do like you know
how you order something from uh uh
whoever you order and they give you a
tracking number on FedEx and you go on
FedEx and what does it say right now
it's on a ship and such and such it just
got to the port in Jacksonville it's
coming to the dealer guess what I
freaking love that yeah so I'm like okay
it's going to be here by Tuesday
fantastic why can't there be that for us
to know your vote if it's officially in
the process it officially got counted
here's where you vote is great I think
there's going to be many different
things like that we can do and by the
way
to say running on the Myra floors not
enough people showed up campaign I don't
think that's a necessary uh uh issue to
run on but to say why don't we make it
more fair and honest you know the whole
story when people say uh do I need to
show my idea TSA yes yes why do we do
global entry for what do we do clear for
why am I show my ID when I'm buying
alcohol why am I doing all this stuff
why don't we make these things more
streamlined those are basic topics that
a person will say I I agree with that if
I gotta go to a club and I gotta show my
ID fine let's figure out a way to make
this thing a little bit tighter and I
think that is a topic that people want
to know more about I just want to say
one thing about
um like a major thing that I've learned
like anyone that watches PVD podcast for
the last two years has probably seen my
progression especially in terms of
politics like I think I've gone from
what I would consider like a JFK
Democrat Clinton Democrat to more of
like a just full-on moderate right now I
voted for Ron DeSantis just to be clear
so you know all the it's good
Adam communist whatever whatever
whatever
I voted for Ron DeSantis just to be
clear here but we always say this the
the the the independent voter the
independent mind in America is the most
important voter in America so for
instance Ricky there's zero percent
chance zero you'd vote for a Democrat
yes hell would have to Freedom exactly
so and there's also
let me finish my point okay okay hold on
I'm gonna come back to us all right
um there's also a zero percent chance
that a far left BLM guy whatever would
ever vote for Donald Trump but where I
like where I'm at right now and maybe
this is my message is to be free from
the constraints of your parties a very
free feeling and to be able to kind of
be an Umpire and call balls and Strikes
and say yeah you kind of [ __ ] up here
nope you guys messed up here that so
today there's everyone wants to live in
well that's my truth that's my truth
well there's the truth and then there's
my truth so for instance you said Ricky
I don't care what you say I don't care
what evidence you show me I don't know I
never said that hold on that's not what
I said you said hold on you said I don't
care what evidence you should never said
that I will never not believe that 2020
election was not stolen that's exactly
what you said no that's no I I said
there's nothing you could tell me to
convince me exactly because well the
evidence is there that it was stolen
okay so my point is this no matter how
hard somebody tries if the Supreme Court
I don't give a [ __ ] but this is my point
brother that you don't give a [ __ ] if
the 6-3 Supreme Court came down and said
by the way we've looked at everything
Joe Biden is the winner of the 2020
election you still wouldn't look let me
tell you let me tell you one thing
because you're living my truth
okay you got to remember
outside of Pat and I don't want to make
judgments on anybody else I lived in
another country I've seen corruption at
its core I've lived in it so like it's
very different when you when you live in
a country where I'm going to give you an
example the one that's president right
now he ran against another guy two
elections ago and they stole it from him
and as a matter even during it's crazy
his name is uh is uh [ __ ]
um uh amlo amlo in Mexico in Mexico the
current president of Mexico during our
election said something's wrong they had
already stolen an election from him the
guy that's the guy sat there from a
different country looked at everything
he said that election is rigged when a
person has had a stolen election he's
been running president many times he's
finally the president now sits back and
says bro that's [ __ ] from another
country from a country that I come from
we see things from a whole different
perspective that they people think like
America is like this perfect country
where everything's fine everything's
good and the government's all intact
[ __ ] there's DEA agents and CI
agents in Mexico trading the cartels
right now
so so it missed me with the whole or the
Supreme Court [ __ ] the Supreme Court
because I didn't excuse my language at
the end of the day the reality is this
I've seen corruption at its core and
when you have DEA and CIA agents in
Mexico training the cartels you can't
convince me otherwise that's fine and
then but here's my response and we see
what's going on in Brazil right now we
see what's going on in in Mexico
this is [ __ ] America
part of you the difference between Eve
to think that okay the difference
between America and the rest of these
[ __ ] [ __ ] other countries
out there is that we believe in the
peaceful transition of power now you can
quote me on this and I'll quote Bill
Maher come 2024 whether Trump gets blown
out or not he will say that he won the
election he will claim that it was
rigged he claimed that 2016 was rigged
and he won dog so like since Donald
Trump has showed up on the scene the
Democrats or every election is rigged
stolen what did Hillary Clinton prior to
that you know who had the biggest
Hillary Clinton just came out 2024 is
going to be stolen she it's two years
from now I'm not even worse already
talking about Trump what are you talking
about Trump Hillary's the one doing it
right the closest election we've ever
had in our history Al Gore in the State
of Florida when George W bush barely won
Florida P.S who was the governor of
Florida at that time oh his brother yeah
Jeb Bush how about that dog
he even said you know what This Thing
Called America is bigger than me I will
say that you won the election George W
bush have it peaceful transition of
power Donald Trump does not believe in
that he does not believe in the peaceful
transition and of course he's been
echoing that sentiment for the last five
years and of course you're going to
stand with it let me tell you let me
tell you real quick well I know Pat
wants to continue so I'm gonna there's
the last thing I'm gonna say my last
thing I'm going to say on the subject
when I tell you that I will never never
re vote Democrat it's not because of how
I feel it's simply because they do not
align with any of my beliefs politically
tax civil uh social in any way shape or
form I they do not align with anything
that I believe in and that's totally
something to do with feelings has
everything to do with me with me looking
at facts it's the party of slavery it's
the party of Jim Crow it's the party at
the KKK and they switch to the 1960s
because it was no longer popular to be
racist and they switched LBJ saying I'm
gonna have these ends voting Democrat
for 200 years
so they they just switched tactics like
what back what he was saying earlier uh
with this this Governor or Senator said
that it was a plantation of politics I
100 believe that's a Democrat Party so
therefore I cannot Vote or even fathom
the idea of voting for something that I
know does not align with what I believe
in and the history of the party and who
they have been and what they represent
and how they destroy everything like the
10 worst cities in the country are run
by democrats I it's so easy to be a
democrat in a in a Republican state try
being a Democrat a republican in a
Democrat state where everything they
touch goes to [ __ ] so therefore I'm I
live in it I live in the [ __ ] you know
what's great so therefore I can't live
like Ricky you said something right I
want to come to you because in a minute
but I want to say I saw a tweet the
other day uh where a 30 uh 29 year old
girl says
for 28 years I've been a Democrat
last year I just became a Republican she
says it's so funny that for 28 years
while I was a Democrat
all my Republican friends were so
patient with me yep but for one year
that I've been a republican none of my
Democratic friends the other one
associated with not tolerant it's so
funny that Republicans were so tolerant
with me Democrats were not here's the
other part yeah but I got to say that's
a [ __ ] statement because I've lived
let me go ahead let me say the other
part the other part is also the
following when you're talking about
Trump and naive and all that other stuff
bro
you believed in Russia jokes for three
years with no proof
35 000 paid by Hillary Clinton you
believed in it and tens of millions of
people believed in it because of
selective hearing because you couldn't
stand one guy no because of the media so
well but that's also form of being naive
because you chose to believe you're a
grown man it's not like you were 17
years old you want to think I'm the only
one that was naive but that's not that's
the country that's the problem that's
also a problem just like half the
country is calling for election
denialism that but but so they're naive
But but so if you want to pick here
there's a big difference
let me just say this part and then we're
going to go to the only person that has
all the experience here to talk about
this and it's right so we're going to go
through in a minute
here's the difference
could they show one thing proof that
there was anything involved with Russia
no zero none is there proof to show that
there's been fraud in elections in the
last six years yes was it enough to flip
not yet and no that's the only
difference there is proof just not at
the level to say well we're going to
change the city or that City there is
zero proof on the Russia hoax part zero
proof on the Russia hoax part so it's
important to know
both of these sides I mean look today is
a uh is a day where Republicans can't
talk a big game but it's also a day that
Democrats can't talk a big game neither
side can talk a big game today it's
gridlock so neither site is right
neither side is wrong and neither side
both sides are also right and wrong
makes sense so both sides have something
to be right about and wrong about both
sides have something to be right and
wrong about it's not like something you
can sit there and brag about but we did
learn something that this wrote The
Weight issue was a real issue right the
only person here that has a kind of
experience in a state that's been
probably at the top in the country for
corruption when it comes down to
elections going all the way back to the
mobs involvement Kennedy Unity more and
more governors in your state have gone
to jail than I think any other state and
you you said earlier yourself you went
for eight years as well because of
something about you know how you there
was a negotiation on the call in the
record we've already talked about that
on the last podcast
yeah yeah so so you you went and against
the most powerful Democrat who was out
there campaigning the last two weeks
which was Barack Obama there's not a
Democrat more powerful than Obama right
now right minus the guys that are
putting the money George Soros but as
far as the voice goes right is Barack
Obama how much of what you listening to
Adam and Ricky going back and forth and
you were a Democratic governor it's very
important for people to know that how
much credibility is there on the
gamesmanship on the manipulation on all
that stuff going behind closed doors
look I really appreciated that
conversation with spirited and it really
was a microcosm of America Adam and yeah
100 and that certainly emotion the anger
the energy involved in it all kind of
really highlights the divisions in our
country and I think it goes down to
fundamental trust I'm not going to
belabor the point I didn't break a law
across the line or take a penny it was a
corrupt prosecution I would have never
believed it had it not happened to me
you think those are the good guys they
would look for the law and do the law
and that makes stuff up or lie or cover
up evidence having said that I had to go
through all of that I'm finally home
look to the future I believe the best
thing this new Republican house can do
for our country Democrats and
Republicans to restore trust is we've
got to have election Integrity to such
an extent that the American people can
believe in the process they have very
real reasons not to believe in it I
don't know who won or who Biden was
declared the winner
I don't want to really litigate all of
that but the fact is a lot of people
don't think that was a fair game do I
believe uh fraud exists vote fraud and
cheating and elections I know it as a
fact coming out of Chicago politics I
also know it it's been at six years in
Congress and hearing stories about the
Democrats from Philadelphia and Detroit
and other big cities now do Republicans
steal votes in places where they control
uh polling the apparatus I'm sure they
do it's human nature we've got to fix
this system the Democrats go out and run
save democracy democracy is at stake I
think in this past election that's
projection let's see if they really want
to save democracy if the Republicans are
willing to put their country first pass
something like guidelines to dictate to
states that they got to do certain
things like Florida did and Georgia did
to clean up their electoral process I
think that's probably the best service
that they can do for our country and in
the long run it's going to save our
democracy I predict the Democrats will
characterize it as something other than
what it is if the Republicans even do it
and you'll see gridlock because
they have a different parties have a
vested interest in how certain things
are right is it fair to say the
criticism Democrats give to the right is
the way they manipulate elections is
through gerrymandering and that's kind
of what they specialize in yes and the
criticism Republicans will give the left
is they do election fraud and that's
kind of how they do it to win elections
so it's like hey if you're going to do
gerrymander we're going to do this but
if you're going to do this we're going
to do that is that a fair criticism that
each side gives to the other side I
think to varying degrees they're both
guilty of that because I think the
Republicans more so on the
gerrymandering right I think Democrats
more so on the stealing votes but let me
tell you
Republicans in places that they control
stuff and no one's looking human nature
and being what it is they're taking some
votes too it's how it is it's sort of
built in to the system it should be
fixed it must be fixed so we can trust
our country and our democracy because
through the hard experience I've been
through and you can think I'm full of
[ __ ] and that I did the things they said
I did I didn't they were legal every one
of them Obama Started they came to me to
make a political deal we had
conversations he went to the White House
they threw my ass into this [ __ ] house
and I wouldn't give in I keep fighting
to this day because of the last senate
seat right there was a senate which was
ultimately reversed by the Appellate
Court that can never uphold that
standard because that was a political
deal Obama wanted to make with me and
they put me there for fundraising I
didn't break that law either but having
said that so I learned lessons you can't
really by the way for some people that
are not familiar with you were a star
that was coming up that would have ran
for presidency some people even looked
at you as you have a very big upside
that it wasn't just about Governor for
you and that's kind of what was going on
and you guys are both from the same
stage so it's a lot of competition
they're going on as well I was the first
Democrat government 26 years in Illinois
which is a microcosm of America at the
time was the fifth largest state I think
it's sixth now we have everything in
Illinois like the United States and um I
was sort of like the new face on the
Block and there were some people that
were speculating Obama came two years
later we both knew each other in the
state legislature he has great skill and
talent life is how it is sometimes it
doesn't go your way having said that
here we are look into the future I think
this new house Republican majority
however small it might be or not as big
as they had expected it was going to be
I do think that resolving the way we do
elections and pushing the states to have
some sort of rules that they have to
follow because we have those for federal
crimes these mandates that federal laws
have why not do it for these elections
so we can have elections in other states
like they had in Florida like they have
in Georgia now because they fixed what
was wrong in Florida that have now made
it where people trust the system can I
just say one thing about even my you
said the Ricky and I the microcos of
America what people don't see behind the
scenes is when we're not on air we're
homies
we're asking about each other's lives or
family or whatever and that's indicative
of what I think what needs to happen to
America even if we have a difference of
opinion
and I'm a moderate person whether it's
politics whether it's lifestyle like I'm
not too far left or extreme either way
okay
Americans we're at this point in America
today where the other side is the enemy
the other side is evil if you voted for
Donald Trump you are a bad American if
you didn't vote for a republican you are
my enemy and I think that is such a sad
point where we're on America today we
can disagree we can talk [ __ ] we can
have dialogue and have but at the end of
the day I would say there's a 90 of
things we agree upon we want to be
healthy we want to make money we want to
have friends we want our family to
succeed we want our kids to grow up in a
nice neighborhood yeah we might disagree
on when someone should have an abortion
or should you should have a certain type
of gun or not the or how much
immigration should impact America these
are very minor nuances that we will
disagree upon but ninety percent of the
time you're going to agree so
what you need to do is like
thanksgiving's coming up you know you
see t-shirts coming along like make sure
you get in a fight with your family
member on Thanksgiving it'll save you
money on Christmas right you don't have
to give your family Christmas gifts
but let's not forget who the real enemy
is American people know that though I
think people know the fact if they watch
our audience they know how you guys are
buddies and we have relationships you
know but there's seven thousand eight
thousand people they might not know that
yeah but the point is like if if and by
the way shout out to Scott Rodriguez
member four months he said something
which is interesting this is so sad but
I knew nothing would change and Joe
Rogan would be wrong my mother is a
Cuban Catholic and against abortion but
was against Roe v Wade she still voted
Republican but wasn't happy about the
abortion issue that's an issue right
there right I want to kind of go to a
couple of these guys I want to finish my
what I was saying but the real animation
stuff I want to come to here uh
alibaba's new member we have a a rock
and roll CEO new member there's a a guy
that just gave a Super Chat and he made
a point I want to ask you guys but if
you want to wrap up your point to your
ultimately all I'm trying to say is this
the other side of the aisle is not your
enemy no okay no no one in America I'm
not talking yeah there might be some
fringed person on the left and the right
that you probably have made yeah
disagreements with but let's not forget
China's still coming
by 2025 China by 2030 that's the enemy
that's that's who we're competing
against let's not forget that some
sometimes sometimes uh Adam uh Alexander
the greats quote till today when I
started the insurance company day one
September 23rd 09 I had a meeting till
four o'clock in the morning in our
office 8550 Balboa Boulevard and I sat
down with seven people that we started
the insurance company with and I said
two of you guys will flip and we'll turn
against the company all of you guys are
excited right number two of you guys are
gonna flip and it's going to happen
within three to six months within three
to six months two flipped against us one
was at a run that we were doing a
charity run that we took 200 people to
participate for this uh charity run that
we did and another one flipped because
the husband and wife went through a
divorce it was very obvious I said
Alexander the Great's quote applies to
every aspect of life this is the thing I
tell my kids I have met the enemy it is
I okay people will try to divide
internally America if America was a
human being America has met the enemy it
is I it is us it is us now realizing
that people with and can be bought can
be sold are for sale it's very very hard
to find people that you cannot buy them
it's very very hard to find people that
cannot be bought you know the saying
everybody has a price tag I don't
believe everybody has a price tag I
don't think everybody if a person
offered right now to buy value to me for
billion dollars you think I'd salvation
right now for a billion dollars you
think I would sell 100 of my content 100
of the podcast 100 of everything and
have no control over it you think we
would sell it today what do you think no
I don't think you a because you don't
need the money and a you appreciate
having a voice and I think that you were
one of the select few people that can't
be bought but I think it should be said
most people can be bought not all you're
right so so the point is those people
that can't be bought today they need to
get a little louder and get a little bit
more involved because we need those guys
to rise up yesterday I had a girl that
was interviewing me here her name is
Leia I don't know her last name so Leia
was interviewing me here she's talking
about what he thinks gonna happen with
America you know with all these
challenges we're facing and you know
economic world that economic Forum Claus
show up all those conversations right I
said you're waking up to True strong men
and women behind closers that were just
chilling you just woke them up that's
all you did and those people are waking
up and Elon Musk if we were to ask Elon
Musk 10 years ago five years ago is it
in your business plan to buy Twitter one
day what do you think you would say
probably zero what caused him to buy
Twitter what happened the last two and a
half years during congratulations covet
got people to say listen man I'm willing
to go here and tolerate some [ __ ] I'm
not go you cross the line with me you're
telling me what to do my kids you tell
me what to do my this the same mothers
and women that are anti-abortion Roe v
Wade all of that you have to also
realize we forget are the same mothers
that were against CRT are the same
mothers that are against trans you guys
know uh uh uh what's his name there's
the prime minister of Canada Justin
Trudeau is the first person to go on a
trance show as a world leader that's
becoming a normal thing some parents are
like I'm not having that you know I'm
not having you talking about the stuff
in my school I'm not having a
congresswoman the other would say the
other day said what's wrong with trans
people being out of school they're a lot
more fun than regular people I love
hanging out who doesn't love to hang out
with trans people those are the types of
things that parents are going to say
dude let's let's just pump the brakes
right there so I'm with you but I want I
want to read this I want to read this
Super Chat that just came in and I want
to get your feedback Gabriel Sanchez
we have to also remember Donald Trump
does not have the voice he had with
Twitter also the Dems are Target
marketing gen Z do you think if Trump
was on Twitter the last six months it
would have made any difference on what
happened last night no any one of you
you're saying it would have got worse
Okay Tyler say no so all of you you're
saying no as well or do you think he
would have been able to influence some
of it I I don't know but I would say
this real quick maybe at the end of this
I could just pick my case on why I
wouldn't write Donald Trump off yet I
think he's very much still the
front-runner to be the Republican
nominee we can talk about that a little
bit DeSantis was a big winner he's has
presidential aspirations I think it's
obvious
but I I have to say that uh one thing
about Donald Trump is he's been written
off many times he always comes back and
when that Billy Bush tape came out and
during the race with Hillary and the
whole Republican establishment started
abandoning their nominee and we're
urging him to get out of the race who'da
thought he would have endured and
survived and overcome that so it's a
very different day in politics today my
hope for president Trump I have a bias
of course I'm grateful for what he did
for me and I think he's really LED our
country in many ways in in a positive
direction I think it's part of this
alignment we alignment that's appealing
to Latino voters and black men and all
the rest joined the Republican party I
think president Trump has reached out to
a different voting block and group to
try to broaden the Republican party and
recognize the demographic shifts in our
country
I'd like to see him become more the
uniter and I don't know he has that in
him can I ask you a question you're
Chicago so so Chicago you know who's the
greatest basketball player of all time
your future is right there okay Michael
Jordan's the greatest basketball player
of all time right you believe that I do
and I had dinner with him once it was
fantastic you put him as the cream of
the crop number one is it fair to say we
all believe the same is the greatest of
all time okay Michael Jordan over LeBron
James any day of the week so let me ask
there's no Jordan deniers here right
yeah but here's a question though well
here's a question though here's the
question
be Michael Jordan for a second okay
the the saying has been he's the Jordan
of dot dot dot and that's been the case
for 25 years okay that label the name if
you were to say how many times people
said he's the Jordan of
that that the number is going to be in a
billions it's we're using it regularly
right Brady doesn't have that nobody
says Gretzky nobody says Willie Mays
nobody says Babe Ruth everybody says dmj
the Jordan okay do you think Jordan deep
down inside is a little bit threatened
about LeBron passing them up you think
Jordan a little bit inside is not happy
about the fact that if LeBron passes 40
000 points you know if he wins one more
chip gets five do you think the Market's
gonna start saying listen and I think
that guy do you think he's threatened by
at all no you're saying zero I'm saying
no you're saying zero or no I'm saying
he's not threatened okay MJ has one
mantle what would you say Rod what would
you say I would say yes I would say it's
incredibly competitive I think he's what
makes incredibly competitive right like
the comment about hey what do you think
about this kid Kobe Bryant the way he's
guarding you well he stole all my moves
like that's still a dig right he stole
all my messages right so so that's the
part where for me you know uh uh the
comment he made you know Trump just made
a comment he said what you know uh uh
this the sanctimonious right he says
Trump mocks Governor DeSantis as Ron the
sanctimonious at Pennsylvania rally how
do you think Trump is feeling last night
going to sleep not even going to sleep
he's up all night last night because
marjor green Kerry Lake all these guys
he's making phone calls he's doing
speeches he's doing all this stuff how
do you think he feels that no matter
what he looks what he reads everyone's
talking about the sentence knowing him
as a true competitor that he has to come
into a room and everybody stops for him
how do you think he feels knowing the
sentence is now the Superstar of the
right like Michael Jordan and LeBron
James just like that and Trump is a
tremendous competitor and the
presidential race is a marathon not a
Sprint and to santis looks really good
right now
um Trump didn't have the best possible
night on the other hand some of his
candidates still won JD Vance won very
well I still think Harry lake is going
to win it otherwise nobody thought that
was going to be happening JD Vance
wasn't like it was going to be a slam
dunk win go take a look he was outspent
four to one yeah exactly
um so you still think Hillary lake is
going to win I do and I I still think
put your money on Trump to be the
Republican nominee you can have a lot of
candidates in that race DeSantis is very
compelling but he's LeBron James to
Michael to Trump's Michael Jordan among
the Republican voters and when you have
a split vote like that 35 percent of the
loyal
Die Hard Trump voters are going to carry
Trump to victory in most of those
primaries but by the way if you're
watching this podcast we can fit 300
people here we're going to do a live
podcast with people being able to come
here live but we're going to do it when
we cross 500 000 Subs if you enjoying
this format the set and what we're doing
give us a sub click on the notification
and give us a thumbs up do you agree
what Roger said Adam
about uh Trump being about Trump and
DeSantis the fact that you know DeSantis
is LeBron Trump is Jordan in this kind
of an argument clearly Trump is
threatened by DeSantis
clearly Trump views himself as
you know the holy of all holies
to use the Michael Jordan LeBron analogy
right the reason that I don't think
LeBron will ever be on Michael Jordan's
level is because at the end of the day
what do you judge people on
championships Bill Russell is one of the
greatest players ever because he has 11
championships okay Mike MJ was 6-0 in
the finals What's LeBron's record like I
don't even know if it's 500 to be honest
exactly he's missed the playoffs yeah so
just on that basis you have someone
who's six and up has never lost in the
finals and you have someone who's
obviously an amazing player probably
will go down as number two of all time
but is not even batting 500 in the
finals so to use the Trump analogy
um Trump I think is more of a LeBron
than an MJ because
what's Trump's record
over the last eight years six years you
want to say one and one in presidential
election not presidential election but
when it comes to midterms he lost in
2018 he lost in 2020 and now he
technically lost in 2022. so my question
is
since 2016
as far as elections go when's the last
time Trump won I will I will say this do
you think do you think if Kerry Lake
wins it's a win for Trump by the way
it's real tight I know that's what I'm
saying if if Kerry let to me if if it's
Marjorie green is that over with or no
oh yeah she blew it out so okay so
that's that's a trump and that's the
biggest trumpster who by the way she
just said the following yesterday I
don't know if you read this or not yeah
she said Marjorie green Taylor asks the
Santas not to run in 2024 we need Trump
this is what she just said her words and
you know what we need in this country is
uh we need strong Republican Governors
like Ron DeSantis we need strong
Republican Governors to fight stay in
the eight years and save their states
not to abandon their states and try to
run for president or any other big
position green said about Trump and
DeSantis as him being the clear nominee
for 2024 my message is for everyone
anyone that's considering running for
president 2024 against President Trump
please support Trump because we need him
back in the White House Green said okay
let me ask my question and we go there
if she won
Oz is his candidate he lost
if Kerry Lake wins I give Trump a w yep
if a lake loses and Marjorie green wins
and Oz loses I give Trump an L but if
Kerry ends up winning
did you hear what she said to the media
yesterday she's being do you have this
clip what she said to the media where
she's like
I think I send it to you if you look up
your text I send it to you about she's
talking to the media and they ask her a
question if you guys haven't seen this
the way she answers it with the level of
certainty uh I'm gonna text it to you
I'm gonna text it to you right here and
just pull it up uh uh you have to see
how she talks she's intimidating yet
respectful yeah so so that's the part
she's intimidating yet respectful Tyler
I just texted it if he can pull this up
if you were to even say how she
communicates I don't put her as
communicating like Trump I see Carrie
lay communicating more like descent is
than like trust I don't see her
communicating like Trump watch this
watch this exchange right here
um watch what she says if you can make
this bigger and put the audio up watch
this just just make the screen bigger so
everybody can see it as well there you
go and then press play go for it Carrie
who are you frankly from CBS News I just
wanted just to follow up on this
question if I may if Donald Trump
announces as expected to be president
and you win the governorship of Arizona
you're likely to be talked about as a VP
Cannon
are you new covering this race because
we talked about this before we talked
about this I've answered these questions
I am going to not only be the governor
of Arizona for four years I'm going to
do two terms I'm going to be your worst
freaking nightmare for eight years and
we will reform the media as well we're
gonna make you guys into journalists
again so get ready it's going to be a
fun eight years I can't wait to be
working with you okay
pause it right there she doesn't talk
like Trump she loves talks like the
scientist everything was respectful
everything was called them out call that
their BS every reported that talks or
she stops and says say your name and who
you're with say your name and who you're
with say your name and who you're with
the level of accountability she's
imposing on the media to no longer play
games people like that if she wins that
is a W for Trump if she loses you're
right do you know her former career yeah
work with Tom zenner for many many years
so she's a journalist she gets it is my
point she knows how to and by the way
what's going to be that college as a
candidate to get in there than somebody
that understands their world and their
level of accountability that's kind of
like imagine like a Tucker or a mad out
running that's an annoying candidate to
run because they know how to play the
game towards the moderator because
they've been in that seat that played
the other side of the game so if she
wins I do think it's a W for Trump and a
lot of the people on the left are not
going to be happy if Lake wins it's a
big gift yeah but if she wins yeah and I
think it's very close right now out of
Tyler what is it 50 49 right 49.7 to 50
to 50.1 I get that but you're dealing
with Arizona Ricky you're not dealing
right in Florida you're not dealing with
Texas it's Arizona hang on I think you
have to look at you have to compare
Florida to Arizona okay Rhonda Santos is
not a trump guy and he kicked the snot
at a Charlie Chris he won by a million
and a half votes in Florida a state that
he won by less than a percentage point
in 2016. Trump is getting his ass kicked
the the American people are sick and
tired of Donald Trump Tyler stop okay
but that's coming from Tyler
you guys are so funny right now even if
Kerry Lake wins you're saying if we're
dead you're saying if so the only Trump
candidate that one is JD brother just
like take a breather and hear me out
just hear me out Tyler okay hear me out
how close
was the sentences Victory four years ago
it was it was a percentage Point can you
actually pull it up to see by how many
votes he won the sentence when he won
very close Okay so I actually want you
to kind of sometimes we forget about
history on what happens with history so
pull it up and see how close the race
was I want to see the number of damn I
said 35 000 I was right yeah by less
than 35 000 votes he won so watch this
watch this
he won by 35 000 votes it's like a
rookie player coming into the NBA being
judged on how they're gonna do
just a year ago nobody knows Kerry Lake
the only people that know Kerry Lake are
people in Arizona in one year boom it's
as if she showed up out of nowhere and
she's averaging 22 points a game in a
rookie year oh I don't think she's got
what it takes to be an All-Star and all
this other stuff she's a rookie if she
wins and plays like that she could be
the second Ron DeSantis now you got a
DeSantis on Arizona and you got a
DeSantis esque in Florida holy [ __ ] a
super team's being put together so let's
not forget this is the first time she's
running you cannot judge a person
running and by the way what did Rondo
before he ran for office what did Rondo
before he won he was a congressman yeah
like in sixth district I think something
like that Florida sixth district he went
from a congress Daytona sixth district
to Governor winning barely by 35. nobody
thought he was going to win this one and
then he wins so if Lake wins lake has a
very big upside and she will be very
annoying let me even make a a a a
prediction here to you maybe even more
annoying to the left and DeSantis maybe
even more annoying to the left and the
sentence and I don't think look let me
let me kind of give this with me or
disagree with me okay
when it comes down to shows okay when it
comes down to shows who was our you know
who's the most famous first
African-American president
what's his name Obama who did he just
launch a podcast with two podcasts with
two years ago who Bruce Springsteen what
happened to their podcast with Spotify
why did they not renew the Spotify why
did they not read this is Obama and
Bruce Springsteen yeah Streets of
Philadelphia because they didn't get the
votes called listeners because you are
not meant to run a podcast at that level
you're not some people are great
co-hosts some people are good hosts some
people can do show all by themselves and
rock the freaking house with no guests
and get eyeballs very few people can do
that we learned Obama and Bruce
Springsteen are not interesting they
need a host First Take has a host in the
middle what's her name Marla what's the
girl that does First Take she's in a
minute she's fantastic host by the way
that she's doing what she's doing there
are very few people that can run as a
one Carrie is a person that can be a
superstar on a team Westport cannot win
as a one okay Duran had to go to Golden
State to win and even there he wasn't a
one Steph Curry was a one Kerry lake is
a one type of a personality okay and
we're just learning about this girl
she's very interesting she's very
intimidating she's very firm yet
respectful did you see the other day
when she walks up the journalist is like
hey Carrie can we do a few questions
with you from CNN Plus have you seen
this one or not did we ever show it on
the podcast or no I don't think we've
ever shown this on the podcast if you
can't find it do me a favor find this
clip here you have to see the lady says
hey Carrie we'd love to do a uh we love
to do it have you seen this one or no oh
my God I wish you could find this just
to show this oh here you go I found it
for you I'm going to share with you here
folks you got to see this and she's
funny that's the part she's funny she's
sarcastically funny you just got the
link if you can pull it up she's
sarcastically funny she's walking up and
this lady comes up to her this lady with
CNN
and she says hey
Carrie we'd love to do an interview with
you we just got a couple questions for
you and then she says oh who are you
with she says I'm with CNN oh okay great
and I look what she tells her just zoom
in a little bit and raise the audio Eric
if we can raise the audio on this one
press play
you don't have a mask on anymore
well we're six feet apart do you have a
minute to chat
um I'll do an interview okay as long as
it airs on CNN plus does that still
exist I didn't think so because the
people don't like what you guys are
peddling which is propaganda thank you
that is a superstar witty you cannot
teach that can you see fetterman doing
that can you see Oz doing that can you
see uh Beto doing that can you see even
Abbott doing that you can't see them
doing that she can do that the scientist
can do that she can do that Obama can do
that there's only a few people that can
do that Hillary Clinton cannot do that
Michelle Obama cannot do that she can do
that this is a star in the making if she
wins they can take a couple different
else sometimes in life you're going to
lose a a person you wanted as a
linebacker you're going to lose this one
but you picked up Joe burrow you picked
up a superstar this is a superstar in
the making okay but again if she does
that go ahead so you're saying Carrie
lake is a superstar in the making I
agree agree with that how is that a win
for Trump Carrie Carrie Lake won because
she said okay but he also did that he
did that for Blake Masters he's uh Lisa
murkowski in Alaska is about to pull out
if you if you go down the ballot
candidates are not going to win but
you're talking about districts versus
States what did he just say what was
your argument right now you said what
Carrie Carrie lake is going to win if
she wins because she's a superstar if
she wins not because of Donald Trump I
that's not okay I never said that though
but but you're saying if Kerry Lake wins
it's a W for true I do think you know
why it's not a w I do think though let
me tell you why though let me tell you
why though here's why he said something
in a very subtle way that nobody here is
talking about okay how DeSantis had
Trump come and say a few words to get
that additional 35 000 votes if Trump
doesn't come out and say that about the
sentence does the Santa's win in 2016.
yes uh not 2016 20 or whatever 2018 does
the Santos win be straight up don't be
emotional here I I don't know that's
tough but possibly not I don't know are
you kidding me 2018 at the peak of trump
with credibility markets killing it
unemployment everything is rocking
African-American minimum wage
everybody's doing very well you you mean
to tell me if Trump at that time doesn't
come and say anything to Santa's wins
you think 33 000 voice descent is going
to move there's a lot of stuff breaking
with Andrew Gillum all I'm saying to you
is if Trump doesn't give that
endorsement that that probably got him
that additional 150 000 votes he needed
yeah okay fair let's put that there 80
percent without Trump he doesn't win
fine now
everybody that's coming up they need
somebody to say I give this guy a check
go ahead and get him pick him up he's
going to be good in sports guys will uh
call a coach from high school and say is
this guy going to be a good player for
us to draft or not okay so he did that
then the sentence went away from being
in the shadow of trump and he became
what
is he in Trump's Shadow today
but at that point they made it seem like
he was he flourished and to be in
somebody that's got his own identity now
and he's doing great for himself Kerry
Lake today just last week she said uh my
husband's my second favorite person my
favorite person in the world is who
Donald Trump that is a victory for Trump
if she wins but I think after she wins
she can spread her wings and get as big
as the Santas on her own identity I
think that's what she can do go ahead
thank you uh an analogy Sports analogy
sure I think Trump feels and I think
he's going to make the case he's already
started doing it he it was interviewed
on news Nation he talked about DeSantis
being ungrateful and I think Trump and
you get that statement from Marjorie
Taylor green
urging him not to run these Trump people
are going to be pressing DeSantis to
remember who made you and I think the
analogy if you're looking for one with
Michael Jordan is Scottie Pippen and I
think Trump would be to Jordan what uh
uh Pippin is to DeSantis and uh Pippin
would not have become the great pair
that he became had Jordan that made him
that great player give him the world
with all to be the player that he is and
I think without Trump four years ago
DeSantis is not in the place he's in
today and I I I commend that one I'll
disagree with that okay and I'll tell
you what I'll tell you why go go ahead
and and and the reason Ford is because
Scott was Scotty was under Jordan's uh
Winks every day they were together
Jordan was shaping his mindset Trump and
DeSantis are not kicking it every day
they're not having dinner together the
Santas is not a product of trump
DeSantis is a Navy sealed you know
he's a commander of a Navy SEAL unit and
Congress and Governor he needed Trump's
help at the time because in 2018 Trump
was the voice of the Republican party I
think DeSantis is his own man and I
think he's making a the other day Dinesh
is like I think he's got to go as a vice
president I think DeSantis is sitting
this morning waking up with us and he's
probably had the meeting last night at
two o'clock in the morning in their
hotel room and they're sitting there
saying what do you think his people are
saying around them you know what they're
saying here's what I'd be saying if I'm
next to him I'm going to say hey uh
how's it feel knowing you're the next
president of the United States right oh
there's no question you're the next
president United States that's what
people said to him last night in his
suite his wife went to sleep if they had
a good time together last night she
called him president if you know what
I'm saying you know what I'm saying
no who's your president who's your
president you honey you honey because he
is on Pace for being that and he earns
the right to have that thing being said
to him behind closed doors the guy shows
toys I don't know if you guys saw his
energy yesterday if you haven't seen it
just go watch the way he spoke okay his
wife overcoming cancer personal life no
excuses showed up he's got the right
first uh uh lady as a wife himself the
way his wife speaks like you guys
remember how Obama would say listen my
secret weapon is Michelle when Michelle
Obama comes and speaks I win the
sentence has the right first lady to go
do that with and and and I think they're
going to have a big upset but I don't
see him as a Scottie I see him as his
own man I want to give some advice to my
Republican friends out there guys mute
can we mute Adam for the next two
minutes go ahead if you want to win
in 2024 which I assume that's what you
want to do go ahead and nominate
to be your president you will win the
White House don't you want us to win
yeah sure if you if you nominate Ron
DeSantis you can tear this down let me
make my Goddamn point Ricky and then you
could spew your nonsense okay
if you want to win in 2024 go ahead and
nominate Ron DeSantis you will walk away
with the White House you will likely win
both houses that's my prediction if you
want to shoot yourself on the foot and
you want to play the 2016 remix we've
all seen that movie and you want to lose
by a narrow margin and do the whole
January 6th Insurrection thing again go
ahead nominate Donald Trump again do you
want to lose or do you want to win the
choice is yours that's your opinion okay
and and double down on that Ricky and
when I bet you a thousand dollars again
that you still won't pay me in 2024. I'm
going to come for double that okay I'm
giving advice to my friends you will win
in 2024 if you pick a DeSantis you will
lose I don't even know who's running on
the Democratic side you will lose with
the Donald Trump he's a toxic candidate
DeSantis is your guy but you probably
won't nominate him because you're in
love with Donald Trump good luck
do you want to did you want to respond
to that Ricky I just I I just go ahead
tell me why you don't want to win
explain to me why you want to lose go
Ricky can we go to the next issue yeah
we do yeah here's here's what I want to
talk about check this out the podcast
has been going on we got roughly 9 000
people on right now we're 1100 away from
hitting 10 000. guys share the podcast
with others because we're about to go to
uh next few topics here we've been
talking for about an hour and 40 minutes
you know what's the one thing no one's
talked about that matters the most not
one person has brought up the economy
yet an hour and 40 minutes okay so
here's the part that no one is talking
about and I said this three weeks ago on
the podcast here's what I said when
Biden went Biden went into our oil
reserve and we saw gas prices dropping
and nobody was bitching about gas prices
and that took place when that happened
that affected votes watch how gas prices
are going to go back up the deal with
Saudi the deal with them stop using our
own Reserve you're going to see gas
prices go back up inflation Wall Street
Journal came out talking about the fact
that if you can pull up this article
Wall Street Journal talking about the
fact that we're going to go to six
percent some investors are afraid that
we're about to go to a two decade high
in the next month that you can see this
article article right here if you zoom
in a little bit some investors bet fed
could lift rates to two decade high now
they're talking about this we haven't
had a point hike we've had three
quarters of a basis point type what if
they do a point hike in the month of
December what if they do they could do
it maybe they're going to go they're
probably going to do a half or three
quarters of a point but maybe they could
do a point half is locked into talk
about great timing if gas prices all of
a sudden go like this on the next week
to the roof just know it was perfect
timing strategy from Biden for the left
to know that the gas prices being lower
got the average voter to say I'm cool
it's not as high as it used to be
what happened with Dow this last two
weeks three weeks that was at what right
now 34 35 a lot of people knew the
Republicans were about to win the house
so the Republicans winning the house the
the people are like listen I'm cool I'm
not going to be doing anything with it
Dow had a 500 Point day how is Dow doing
right now by the way I'm Kirsten 300
points it's up 300 points s p up 22.
there you go you know what the market is
saying that was at 33 thou just a month
and a half ago two months ago Dow hit 28
dollar 28.5 and it's at thirty three
thousand when this thing goes up the way
it has it helps the midterms the economy
in the last four to six weeks helped the
midterms a lot the economy in the last
four to six weeks now when we hear about
what's going on with uh home value
losing a trillion and a half dollars of
equity in the last five months this
hasn't yet hit in 2023. it's going to be
very interesting what happens to the
market now that there is no gaming the
system or the economy meaning you're
about to really find out what our
economy is like the next three to six
months so some of it in the last three
months could have been fake some of it
in the last six weeks could have been
fake there is no reason to game the
economy the next six months meaning if
[ __ ] hits the fan with the economy the
next six months what's Biden going to
say well you know this is because the
house won him this is because there's so
many things to blame but whatever
happens to the economy the next six
months is the real economy no
gamesmanship on both sides it's going to
be very very interesting Tom I want to
go to here with all these things that
we're looking at right now what do you
think is going to happen with the
economy you're seeing the same stats I'm
seeing what do you think is going to
happen to the economy post midterm
elections I think you're exactly right I
think the first thing that's going to
happen is the shoot the other shoe is
going to drop on gas prices because the
manipulation with the Strategic
petroleum Reserve stops because remember
he can only do that once and then they
have to backfill the petroleum Reserve
it's not like some magic Genie fills it
up at night you have to go back and fill
it up again so you can use it again it's
like a savings account of oil for when
the United States States is in trouble
that's I think what people should look
at that spr when you hear that
and you don't have that trick to make
the prices run so I think gas is going
up number one and there hear me now and
hear me clearly there may be gridlock in
Washington they may not be getting
anything done or maybe no change but
I'll tell you where there is still going
to be change and that is at the grocery
store because the prices are continuing
to go up and so there may be grid like
in Washington but there's not going to
be gridlock in their wallets and their
purses are there credit cards because
the price is still going up prices are
going up the market is still reacting to
values of
you know accelerated assets and these
assets went up in value because we
printed money so the average person
needs to look at it and say the stock
market is going up for reasons that are
more related to what we did printing
money and less related to the health of
the economy because when they look at
their wallets they go to the grocery
store they go to get a haircut they go
the thing the prices are going up and I
do not think it's going to be a happy
fourth quarter if you were taking a look
between the lines at the election you
were seeing there were polls out there
that were saying people were actually
going to take Thanksgiving off did
anybody see some of this that they
weren't going to spend as much on the
big meal and they maybe weren't going to
travel to a family member if it required
air travel or some real using gas
traveling five miles is that they might
take Thanksgiving off compared to the
way they would spend in other years
friends that's two weeks from now so I
think we're going to see a shoe drop on
gas prices I think we're already hearing
whispers about her hurting Americans
that are going to modify their
Thanksgiving plans is supposed to be a
time of Thanksgiving getting the family
together you know remember
thanksgiving's a neutral holiday it's
not Hanukkah the first part of December
and Christmas the last half of December
and then Festivus for the rest of us
some other point of December it's you
know it's a good podcast of this
reference Thanksgiving is supposed to be
all of us taking a break and then
spending what we don't have on Black
Friday but I have a question I think
that's what's going on Pat I I think I
think things are are right around the
corner from real and really bad and I
think people are going to sit back and
go well wait a minute now what now what
does the news media talk about now that
this mini series called the midterm
elections is over Tom question for you
and Pat as well as business guys uh odds
everything's about odds what are the
odds that over the next two years that
the economy
goes up
stays flat or goes down what do you
think the odds are we haven't reached
bottom yet I'd love to know what other
people think and I mean what do you
think do you follow these things now as
closely as you did when you were
Governor where economic statistics could
move your constituents and be a great
concern what are your thoughts no I
think everything you just said is right
I think exactly the manipulation of the
Strategic petroleum Reserve was clearly
for this election cycle and I think that
it was artificial and I think we have a
real energy problem and a shortage and I
think we're going to see gas prices go
up I think the economy will continue to
be a problem I think what you guys are
talking about increase in uh interest
rates all of those things are going to
be sort of like how it was in the late
70s when Jimmy Carter was the president
and that's why whoever wins that
Republican nomination 2024 I know we
talked about the economy this time
around but if this continues to get is
worse and not better
I think it's going to be a change
election in 2024 and the Republicans
whoever their candidate is I think we'll
have a real good chance to win now if
the economy improves it's a very
different story but I'm betting that
what you just said is likely to happen
I don't think we've seen the bottom yet
before we can talk about what are the
odds of it getting better I don't think
we've seen the bottom first you have to
call the bottom the late Mark Haynes
called the bottom magnificently in 2009
on cnbc's Squawk on the street and he
was the First Financial reporter to do
so and he was dead on he said this is it
this is it this is it I'm calling bottom
and I I don't think we're there yet and
I'm waiting for a voice to do that but I
don't think it's going to be this year
and I don't think it's going to be first
quarter
yeah I think uh again everything is we
will see nobody knows but if gas prices
go up guess what tapping into the
reserves to get the average American
who's not feeling a pain of gas was an
effective strategy by Biden's
Administration especially knowing this
is the lowest level of approval rating
by President since Truman not even
Carter by the way it's lower than Carter
it's at truman levels so if the if the
gas prices goes up you'll see it
interest rates are going to go up
mortgage prices are going to go down
unemployment hasn't even been hit yet we
still have to see those things taking
place I think 2023 is going to be rude
awakening when it comes down to the
economy we still haven't gone through
but again we will see I want to show
this chart here on where billionaires
were putting their monies at okay if you
can zoom into this picture so we can
look at because at the end of the day
880 million dollars were put in
different packs by these billionaires if
you look at Soros 129 million dollars
went into go a little lower so we can
see see exactly what it's like I see it
over here hang on one second so I'm with
you because I can't demonstrate yeah in
a democracy pack two okay you got Sam uh
bankman freed uh he's the guy of uh FTS
the guy that lost all the money he
wanted to give all his money to the
Democrats 39 million dollars went into a
few different things protect our future
pack color of change pack uh not color
of change pack it was mainly that and
then House Majority packed GMI pack
Elizabeth and Richard uh olhein gave a
lot of it to Club for Growth Action some
to a restoration pack Wisconsin Truth
pack and then he also put some money
into what's the last one there I can't
see the last one it goes into others Ken
Griffin 66 million dollars Jeffrey asked
48 Steven Schwartzman 38 33 million
dollars into Congressional leadership
fund he put into Senate leadership fund
he put in American leadership action and
he put some of it in others and then you
had Peter Thiel put 30 million into
protect Ohio values pack and then he put
into saving Arizona pack okay obviously
he was betting on you know Oz and uh uh
late against JD Vance JD Vance that's
right that's right JD Vance and uh
that's right Oz is uh Pennsylvania uh
Vance says Ohio which paid off and then
so a lot of billionaires are getting
involved the question becomes the
following is this a good thing or a bad
thing and will this ever stop like you
know for somebody that ran do you think
we can ever you know prevent these guys
from getting involved and if we did how
different would the election be I think
it's a bad thing and I have unclean
hands on this Ken Griffin gave me money
when I ran for governor
um pritzker the current governor who
worked for me he gave money to my
campaign when I ran for governor uh and
then after I had won
um and pritzker being the heir to the
height Hotel Fortune has spent
tens of millions of his own money to win
re-election the first time 175 million
dollars I don't know what he spent this
time probably more to win re-election
um and so I think look the Republicans
spent more than four billion dollars in
this election cycle 4 billion the
Democrats just about 4 billion
this is
this is obscene and I think really a
problem for our democracy what's the
solution people don't like it and this
sounds like a Bernie Sanders kind of
approach but I feel like you should
limit the amount of money that
candidates can spend in campaigns I
think the broadcasting media should give
free advertising to candidates you got
to figure out who's a credible candidate
or not there's got to be some sort of
fair way to do that and I think their
taxpayers might have a vested interest
in public financing of campaigns and
take the money out of it I think what
you're referring to is obviously
campaign Finance reform what was it in
2010 that was the Supreme Court ruling
for Citizens United 2014 I know that
case real well because that's why I went
to prison and things like that exactly
because our first time I think that's
been a disaster for campaign and and big
money in politics and where you can
basically buy elections and we've seen
here by that chart I know we can pull it
up it's on the left and the right people
are given millions and millions and
billions of dollars and I mean whether
you're a Bernie Sanders guy or not
or an AOC person or not or a Marjorie
Taylor green or not
they're getting money by individual
donors rather than big
you know ridiculous billionaires that
can just basically influence and
buy-elections I think that citizens
united decision by the Supreme Court has
had a very negative impact on America
thank you and I'm glad he said that I
got to add another thing though I
thought this at first was a good thing
it's a bad thing when Obama was going
crazy in a positive way and it was
setting the world on fire back in 2008
and he was Raising small daughter
contributions from people all over the
country and one month he raised 100
million dollars that was unprecedented
and it was coming from everyday people
sending in Small Checks my first thought
was this is good for democracy because
what it's doing is it's deluding the
influence of the special interest groups
the Pacs and those who do business
around government right and dilutes the
influence of these billionaires what
it's done however is
Trump has now become and the Republicans
have become Grassroots fundraisers so
they've got their group of small dollar
donors what that does is it divides the
politics you can't now compromise with
the other side and keep your fundraising
base of all those people who like that
sort of extreme position or those hard
positions that some of them take and it
what it does is it discourages
compromise finding common ground and it
continues to polarize that country
that's why I think it might you know I
don't really know the full answer but I
know that ain't working the billionaires
ain't working uh there's too much money
in politics the campaign seasons are way
too long the the media makes all kinds
of money on the TV ads everybody has a
stake in this as Citizens I think
everybody should sacrifice including
taxpayers we should limit the amount of
money that's spent and these media
people should be able should have to be
able to do it for free and put some of
these ads on
um but I don't expect that any of that
will happen in the near the citizens you
know United decision in 2010 is there a
chance that that's brought up again in
in the Supreme Court again these days
how does that work yeah but it would
probably be even more reaffirmed by that
conservative court because they've taken
the position that and under the First
Amendment you have a right to give as
much as you want it's your money so a
lot of people will complain about George
Soros the other the things that he's
doing and the negative ramifications
but isn't that tantamount to exactly
what this is it's like if you don't want
George Soros buying elections then don't
propose these citizens United's
amendments right or these books
yes
so your question is what I'm just saying
like you're saying that if they did
revisit the citizens united ruling today
with the conservative Supreme Court that
are probably will reaffirm the decision
yeah so it's
essentially saying keep doing what
you're doing George Soros I mean you're
cool just think about it this way
somebody just commented right now Andrew
huff and gave ten bucks and he said Adam
Mark Zuckerberg bought the 2020
elections for the Democrats and split
over 400 million dollars on dropboxes
that's a lot of money to be used and
that's a lot of influence by the way
look what happened they lose 800 billion
dollars of valuation with Facebook the
guy loses a hundred billion dollars of
his net worth and they're letting they
announced today a day after elections
very appropriate day after midterm
election they're laying off 11 000
employees today nobody thought it was
going to be a number that big but all of
these things that are going on when you
guys are going back and forth talking
about this I don't know if I'm
comfortable with people putting that
kind of money into it and I don't really
know what would happen if the money was
out you would actually need to do the
workout shake hands talk to people
here's the one thing that was very
interesting with issues yesterday do you
remember when Romney was debating uh
Obama and he came off the first and
second debate I think he won both
debates second debate was a better
debate for him and it was going to the
third debate and on the third debate
Romney went and started talking about
salad and health and some weird stuff
and didn't talk about Benghazi didn't
bring it up one single time and all the
pundits afterwards are like what the
hell are you doing what are you talking
about I'm on a flight with Bill O'Reilly
and Dennis Miller I'm going to uh Vegas
from LA to a party or wedding or an
event Bill O'Reilly's sitting right next
to me Southwest Airlines okay I'm
leaving Burbank so it's an easy
40-minute flight I said Bill what just
happened with Romney you know he says
look I'm doing my show right now when
we're going there here's what took place
okay what took place during this time
Ricky is while they were going there he
called Obama and he says Hey his Camp he
says look I want to get Obama on my show
and they're like and then he called
Romney and Romney's like no we're good
we're going to win it and he says I call
Obama's camp and Obama's Camp says it's
over our biggest fear was that Romney
was going to bring up Benghazi but he
didn't he played softball he lost the
election because his third debate was
very big and that's what gave Obama the
victory right I don't know what would
happen if some of these gamesmanship is
out to see how who would rise up and win
and the timing of issues and all this
stuff but today crime how many people
saw issues talking about crime I don't
know how much they're talking about
crime and crime is a real thing can you
pull up the statistics here with crime
okay so this this if you look at this
year since 1990 till today Tyler can you
explain to us this chart because I know
there's a lot of them out there explain
this chart to us so this top the line
here is crimes committed per hundred
thousand people and then the bottom is
the percentage annual change by year so
in 2020 there was a 29 Spike up from
five crimes per 100 000 people to six
and a half crimes and and what's what's
interesting is in New York in L.A
homelessness you know Portland who was
all about you know defunding the police
is now all about hey we kind of need the
police all the people that were part of
the defund the police camp are now
coming back saying we need cops the
African-American commuters are like
listen we definitely need cops what are
we doing the families the mothers are
like we definitely need more cops New
York yesterday we showed the interview
with hokel on MSNBC what was the host
name Adam that uh on MSNBC Stephanie
rule yeah and she's like look okay I'm
not feel I'm not comfortable going out
there in the streets I'm not comfortable
going out there talking to people and
when I'm talking to people from the left
the right or the middle no matter who
we're talking to everyone's a little bit
concerned do you know one of my agents
John says I got to show you something I
just ran into I said what is it he says
let me show you this gun so he takes
this gun out I said what are you doing
with a gun in my house he takes the gun
out to show I got it right here
he takes this gun out and shows it to me
I said this is what is this what are you
doing he says Pat it's a non-lethal gun
that you can buy for 500 bucks and
everybody needs to have it he has it in
his Lambo okay he says I got this
everywhere I go it's illegal anybody can
have it you don't need a license all you
need to do is be over 18 years old so I
looked at it I call one of my I said buy
one of those for us that comes in well
then eventually I said now I like this
product we got to reach out to them
Berna and learn more about it so we do
then Berna from their headquarters sends
a bunch of people to the vitamin
headquarters and they come in this is
the gun
okay it's got
projectiles which is like a ball and
they got different kind of projectiles
one of them this one right here the
projectile is a pepper ball if you hit
somebody with this it drops them and you
can't see or breathe you're having a
hard time breathing and seeing for 30 to
40 minutes okay so it stops it
immediately because you know there's the
other taser gun or whatever it is this
one you take out you put these things in
there it's like an air gun but 60 feet
you can shoot and drop somebody you can
spray it 60 feet so it can drop a guy
threatening my family this is a pepper
spray it can drop anybody and they they
can't do anything for 30 to 40 so you
can run away or they have them where
it's just a projectile and you just hit
somebody it hurts your drop right
there's many clips of this burn a gun so
whether you're Pro Second Amendment or
you're not I believe everybody needs to
own one of these things here we called
them we brought them by the way they
have not paid us a single penny this is
the only sponsorship where I haven't
taken money from them everybody else
that comes you got we reached out to
them we said we believe in your product
and we said we want you to give a
discount to our audience if they want to
buy one of these if you're a salesperson
if you drive Uber if you do Lyft if you
do GrubHub if you're running late night
uh DEA is a customer up there law
enforcement ATF a hundred thousand
Americans have bought one of their guns
they just launched this three years ago
by the way it's one of the fastest
growing companies in selling these types
of guns their competitor I think is uh
what's the one I just called a minute
ago the taser competitors that they have
you can buy one of these no one's going
to know what's going to happen with
protesting the the rape with crime all
that stuff and different by the way you
can have this in California you can have
it in Illinois you can have it and all
that stuff you can study the
jurisdiction and we have a link below
for people that actually want to buy one
of these for yourself or your five they
even have it in a rifle that shoots 100
feet away it's a pretty sick product
that they have you're not going to get
arrested the risk nowadays many people
when they have a gun for protection and
they shoot somebody with it is that if
you do harm the other person and kill
them they even if it was self-defense
you can still go to jail you should go
to jail but with this you're protected
and it's still safe and the oppositions
there's a video of this on YouTube
that's got 20 million views where a guy
breaks into the house the owner of the
house puts the gun out points it at him
the other guy thinks it's a real gun
it's not a real gun never shoots it the
guy goes away it's projectiles so my
suggestion to you I highly recommend you
go buy one for you for your spouse or
anybody in your family especially if
you're a business owner have one of
these for yourself put the link below I
think they're going to get a discount
when they go buy their product the
projectiles uh uh and that's a shout out
to burn up because we I believe in this
product go ahead There's real life
experience that I've I've come across
with Berna I do Consulting work for a
logistics company called CDL 1000 which
incidentally Inc magazine just said is
one of the fastest growing companies in
the country and one of the truck drivers
that they that they work with was
accosted by some Thug criminal and had
one of these burner guns and was able to
extricate him from what otherwise would
have been a victimization by him so
this is really interesting I just my
question is if you've been to prison and
you have a felony albeit as wrong as it
was can I still get one of those yeah I
think you want to talk to your lawyers
and your state and you've been in
Illinois but I think again it's not seen
as a Lethal Weapon It's a non-lethal gum
would projectiles to protect yourself
look at the argument that non-lethal
it's a non-lethal God I got to give a
shout out to Ricky because he agreed to
let me shoot him with a burner did he
really so just as I said with the
chemical organization I didn't want to
do it but he said no I got this I got
some boots and guess my ideas
so there you have it so there's a
burning story right there anyways very
rarely do we reach out to guys but we
reached out to these guys and if you
have if you don't have one go get
yourself a burner gun and that video on
that website you can see a bunch of us
shooting it at the office testing it out
okay uh uh next Story by the way are you
are you thinking with what's going on
right now with crime do you think here's
an interesting question for you that's
what I thought about yesterday
so you know how sometimes in sports a
team wins and they win in a big way
players make phone calls to say hey get
me to go on that team because I want to
win a championship next year you know
what I'm talking about like in sports it
happened hey look man I want to go
Milwaukee like Tucker keeps moving from
Team to team to win the champ I'm gonna
go to Miami yeah I'm gonna go to this
guy I'm going to go to Philadelphia
Veterans very common they'll take the
veteran minimum and go to a team that
they think there's a chance by the way
what happened with the mayor of La is it
still a runoff or is it done who who won
in La did he lose Democrat win he lost
okay Democrat one Democrats still won so
Caruso didn't win can you pull that up
with Caruso by the way I went to law
school with Chris he was in my
graduating class really yeah was he a
stud back then he was a total stud he
was way up on top I never knew the guy
because he was way up on high and I was
struggling there with C grade so I never
knew the guy and uh he went on to be a
billionaire and I went out this shows
him winning yeah this shows him he's 10
45. uh Rick yeah this is 7 10 am
you know this is right now last updated
10 46 a.m
it's seven in L.A is it over or is it
done or no 40 45
wow he was he was oh 44 of votes are in
okay so we don't see the Republican uh
he was a republican as a republican he's
a wink wink Republican but running he's
a Democrat he's a billionaire real
estate Karen bass she's a congresswoman
oh God so he's running as an independent
or as he changes parties so he he became
a Democrat
um he's uh his father was like oh but
Budget rent a car or something so he's
very wealthy in law school very well and
then he took that to the next level kind
of like Trump Democrats are running
Democrats he's been a lifelong
Republican he was a big donor to
Republicans but he decided to run for
mayor so is he the kind of guy that that
people believe can clean up La that's
what they're hoping that this guy could
do but here's my question for you after
what happened last night with the way
Florida won okay would what happened
when New York a lot of people were
hoping for hocal to lose a lot of them
that race was a lot closer than anybody
thought it was going to be okay to lose
47 to 52.5 or whatever in a state like
Florida in a state like New York is
insane do you think that Victory by
hokel do you think the victory by
Newsome do you think the victory in
these blue states that some of the
people are hoping for change do you
think that's going to cause the second
wave of people leaving or do you think
that's going to do no damage nothing
people will stay put I think in
California I can tell you Pat people
were waiting to see if Newsom was going
to win or not to make a move to some of
the people to move yes okay because some
people like well they were moving they
were moving too early and they're saying
well what if he loses then we would move
away from our families and where we grew
up so I could tell you I know tons of
people that were waiting for this
election
to determine if they were going to move
from California or not and now I I
already know what the decision is going
to be Tom
no I think there's definitely a second
wave and there's a few people I've
talked to that had next to zero hope in
Newsome moving but they were also
looking at real estate prices timing of
selling a house and moving but they were
actively making plans and they're still
making plans and I think you're going to
see another wave going out of California
and look you can see the layoffs are
happening in Silicon Valley I mean there
are a lot of layoffs that are happening
there and let me tell you not all those
people that work for those companies are
are True Believers on the political side
of the spectrum a lot of them quietly do
their job as an engineer and everything
and you got to keep your mouth shut
because as you pointed out the young
woman that said hey for so many years I
was a democrat in my few Republican
friends kind of tolerated me and
everything was good the minute I said
that I was Voting Republican suddenly my
friends were very assured and just all
over me and that happens inside these
companies and you see a lot of layoffs
and a lot of people I think it's a non
trivial second wave and it's really the
first wave really hasn't stopped if you
look at the statistics year over year I
think the wave's going to Crest higher
that's probably a way do you agree
when I was governor of Illinois Illinois
was the fifth largest state in the
nation today's the sixth largest state I
think that the Exodus from Illinois will
continue so I agree with both of these
guys I think it will continue and it
will continue to further divide our
country into the divided States of
America
you think that's the direction that's
going to happen so you think so you
think it's going to be a place where
Democrats feel safe living in a place
where it's pro-choice anything
Republicans are going to live in a state
that's going to be pro-business Pro
Freedom Pro freedom freedom of speech
yeah I think it's less about the
abortion issue on this particular case
more about the business opportunities
crime first and foremost crime and uh
whether or not you see any political
leadership that's willing to do the hard
things to fight crime and slow it down
and reduce it and business uh uh climate
but the reason why broad approachio is
because some women are leaving to
approach or state from a pro-life State
some are actually moving
I think that's right actually come to
think of it yeah um I do think that's
right so you know if you look at this
chart here if you can pull it up Eric so
the audience can see it this this kind
of shows you uh employee donations to
midterms uh candidates by party okay
blue being Democrat red being Republican
look at Netflix
99.6 of the donations was to the
Democratic party only point four percent
was to the Republican Party obviously
they're not biased at all at Twitter was
98.7 at Airbnb is 98 Apple 97.5 stripe
97 lift 96 Google alphabet 96 Salesforce
95 Facebook 95 Tesla 94 eBay 93 PayPal
92 Microsoft 92 Amazon 89 Uber 81
Hewlett Packard 80 Intel 78 look at
Oracle time at the bottom with you know
Larry Ellis and it's like look man
fourth or fifth richest man he was on
the billionaire at least a minute ago
when you had on the donors 66 here 33.9
I think a a big part of this the reason
why I'm showing this is because if if
you are trying to use social media and
you're telling me there is no bias that
the people that are working at some of
these companies it's a lie and you got
99 that are only going one side I I feel
bad for the point four percent
Republican that works at Netflix think
about how they view that person it's
kind of like look uh can we get like
five Republican employees here just to
kind of even things out so they don't
say we're fully Democrat just so we can
always use those three guys or five guys
but what do you think about when you see
numbers like this Tom
uh uh well I look at where most of these
were headquartered
um Silicon Valley and Microsoft up there
in Washington you know the land of the
Birkenstock so I I think you you've got
that and you also have an emerging
generation that's part of this and I I I
think there's a lot of leadership that
thinks you have to be on the right side
of History because I don't believe these
donations necessarily reflect the true
playing field that's out there I don't
think it represents their customer sets
and you know it's also very very
interesting a lot of these companies and
there's a couple of them in there they
have policies about what you don't talk
to your customer about so we may be
giving it this way but when we talk to
our customers I know it's this way at
salesforce.com it's like our customers
are going to be from both sides of the
aisle our customers are going to have
all kinds of viewpoints and we can't
bring our personal political views and
offend our customers because if you look
look at the statistics according to the
election it's what 48.5 of the United
States is on the other side so not one
of these folks is going to want to give
up 48.5 percent of their customers so
how they are in their hearts and in
their personal views is not how they
necessarily behave in front of their
customers although there's companies
like apple that are you know definitely
way out there in very open and
Progressive publicly Adam what do you
think about when you see this no I think
this is actually a very very powerful
stat right here because these companies
I mean down the list these are the
companies running America running the
world for that matter okay and
that you know when you talk about cancel
culture
um here's a reason why these are all the
platforms like when we sat down with
Andrew Tate not only did it get banned
from Twitter and YouTube and Facebook
and meta and Instagram and Discord then
it happened to be PayPal and stripe next
it was Uber and Lyft and I kind of joke
do you think that all these Silicon
Valley guys are on a text message
together just kind of like how we're on
a text message with buddies and the
answer is yeah of course they're kind of
there's a group think mentality the
problem is
these are the people running America but
this is not representative of what
America is let's use an example of Jimmy
Kimmel the other day like Jimmy Kimmel
has lost half his audience yep because
he's completely done and by the way the
same thing for uh Colbert to a lesser
extent Fallon
um what's your other guy Seth Meyers
they've doubled down on their hate for
Trump not a chemical level though
camel I think are at the same level I
think Fallon is like you know a little
less yeah but that's my point yeah is
that just because you have a certain
ideology or a certain business model
doesn't mean you should alienate the
other half of America
right so I think it's a poor business
model but it is a a Telltale sign of why
certain people get canceled right or why
certain types of content gets a strike
because look at the people running these
companies it's a very powerful message
here well you said it one time pat
remember when you talked about who was
the most the most five more most
powerful is it the government the
President social media and business I
think universities universities
you you talked about this and mainstream
media and mainstream media and I think
this is showing a lot going back to that
point when you talked about that by the
way can you pull up the concept of
capitalism versus corporatism pull up
the difference between capitalism versus
corporatism just put difference between
capitalism and corporatism and then zoom
in okay if you if you zoom in here if
you zoom in right there for the
definition so we can see it capitalism
is an economic system that recognizes
individual rights while corporatism is a
political and economic system that seeks
social justice and equality among
individuals right so when you look at a
the model of how much money they're
putting into the left or the right and
you're seeing the amount of power that
they have you're seeing an example of
corporatism here where the the here's
Netflix that dictates what content your
kids watch they're putting 99.6 onto one
side here's Facebook that's dictating
how many people get your viewership
they're putting their money on one side
not only that you know Zuck is another
you know however much money he put into
it I think it's a interesting thing when
you see that data by the way if there's
another one of these companies that
somebody from the right like a Elon Musk
can come out of nowhere and buy who
would that be if there's a company that
can be bought by somebody on the right
at a discount at this point it's
Facebook are you kidding me how much
money they've lost over the last 12
months snap
you thinking snap
you're thinking he brings something to
do like a tick tock thing right if
you're talking about something that's
depressed they're down 92 percent their
stock price is down 92 which means that
they're
the ability to buy them the price is
down 92 percent I don't know that it's a
very good platform but that's a social
that is a troubled highly discounted
social media platform that someone could
pick up if they thought they could do
better
what about these other platforms that
have shown up the rumbles of the world
the parlors of the world what is it
tumblr what are these other things uh
whether it's truth social do these
things have a place in in mainstream
media not not parlor because it's tied
to Kanye that that thing is done done
for now that's going to take a time out
for a minute I think Rumble for sure
they're not going away now they're
getting bigger and bigger uh they had a
chance to put Rumble out of business a
few years ago they didn't do it it's
backfiring on them because Rumble is
taking market share and they're raising
money left and right and they're picking
people up they come and create content
with us Russell Brand is now making
content on Rumble you're getting all
these names and they're taking market
share away from YouTube from of course
YouTube from from a lot of different
places they're taking market share
alphabet yeah alphabet and and and
that's going to continue to happen but
I'm talking about who has the funds that
when you look at these numbers I'm
talking about these big boys okay these
companies these numbers that Netflix
Twitter so Twitter's now musk Airbnb
apple and no one's going to buy apple
apple is a at this point it's a country
of its own stripe lift Google Salesforce
Facebook you know these are influential
companies you know and who even has that
kind of money to go buy some of these
guys it's going to be interesting
because Twitter being bought by Elon
Musk was probably one of the best things
that happened but will any of these
other guys go for sell I don't know
we're going to see what's going to
happen here anyways uh fun podcast we
went through a lot of different topics
Adam and Ricky are still friends here I
will tell you this if you're here with
us and you're like us just so you know
don't get it twisted we're fully
convinced the future looks bright these
hats are right now selling like hotcakes
we're on the side it says future looks
bright and on the bottom of the lid it
says future looks bright with the
vitamin logo you can buy these in white
black and just recently what do you call
these with the back that's like this
style or snap what's it called Snapback
the snapbacks just came because people
asked for the white and black is now
here if you haven't yet ordered your
future looks bright hat put the link
below in chat in description and comment
but with that being said I think we're
doing podcasts again tomorrow Dave Rubin
in the house oh Dave rubin's in the
house tomorrow oh Dave guys interesting
yeah so I'll be here too Dave Rubin will
be on the podcast tomorrow I think we're
going to do it back at the other place
uh in the vault but we'll be there
tomorrow uh together Rod appreciation
for coming out your Insight is always
specifically at a time like this you can
give Insight that many others can
because of your experience it was great
having you on thank you I gotta give a
shout out to the team to put this all
together I mean Jorge Eric can't wait
for this you're kidding me life are you
cannot wait for this to be alive with
300 people sitting here screaming
hollering let's go
we're looking forward to that we'll do
that once we cross 500 000 Subs if you
want to be part of the text distribution
list to get the update once we're
selling tickets because it's going to
sell out like this yeah text uh text
podcast to
310-340-1132 once again
310-340-1132 the ward podcast texted to
310-340-1132 for everybody that was with
us
thanks for joining us have a great day
everybody we'll see you guys tomorrow
take care bye bye-bye